to meet their own rooted six thousand
more of course i'd be very happy to meet
with my honourable friend to discuss
this issue further smb spokesperson
thank you mr speaker times higher
education have reported that several um
uk universities are providing afghan
achievement scholars with considerable
financial assistance from food vouchers
to laptops whilst this is to be
commended it is shocking that the
financial contributions of the uk
government is not covering what they
need so what discussions has the
minister had with colleagues within fcdo
to increase the financial contribution
to properly support these afghan
students
thank you mr speaker i welcome the
contribution that universities are also
making to afghan
refugees and i will meet with the
honourable member to detail exactly what
the government has done to support those
studying here
thank you mr speaker will the minister
join me in thanking the head teacher and
the staff out of iball valley school in
my constituency
uh they're in discussion for a much
needed refurbishment can the minister
advise me what is the government's plan
for upgrading the estate of schools that
deal with children with severe learning
difficulties yeah
ernest uh well i i thank honourable
friend for his question he knows i
recently visited an excellent
alternative provision setting within the
academy for central bedfordshire he will
know we are investing an extra 2.6
billion pounds between 2022 and 2025 to
deliver an additional 30 000 places and
improve existing provision for children
with sin and of course i would echo his
thanks
schools in east hill have gone above and
beyond to ensure that kids have kept
learning during the pandemic and i thank
each and every school leader teach and
support staff
for that but they've been badly let down
by this government ten thousand
six hundred school dead were lost last
term
as a result of this government's failure
so when will the minister
adopt the ambitious comprehensive school
recovery plan
put forward by the shadow secretary
state which will
in fact do what needs to be done
or gentlemen but we have a strong plan
for recovery in schools we have a strong
plan for attendance and it's absolutely
vital but we make sure because there has
been unavoidable absence as a result of
kovid we make sure we crack down on the
avoidable absence uh which was a
reason for one of my visits for
northeast just last week jonathan gallis
thank you mr speaker in so-called trip
we're proud to be the home of
staffordshire university but sadly it
seems the council culture has arrived in
our doorsteps after the world karate
made formal complaints about criminology
professor james treadwell for tweeting
that transgender women should not be
allowed in women's prisons after citing
research that found that half of women
in prison have experienced emotional
physical or sexual abuse will my
honourable friend share with me her
despair this tiny extreme minority who
wish to silence anyone whose opinion
they disagree with i will vulnerable
friend join me in lending their support
to professor treadwell
thank you mr speaker this is a
government that is committed to ensuring
free speech on our campuses which is
exactly why we are honouring our
manifesto commitment and bringing to the
house free speech legislation i would
like to point out that the university of
sussex is already being investigated by
the office for students and other
universities should take note of this
thank you volkscroft thank you mr
speaker research published by the social
market foundation has shown that
students
accepted to university from
working-class backgrounds are more
likely to hold a b-tech qualification
than their peers
after failing my gcses as a
working-class 16 year old it was a
b-tech in performing arts that got me
back into education and ultimately into
university now the minister's already
been asked this question by the
honourable member for westminster
north does the minister agree that the
decision to hastily remove b-tech
funding makes a mockery of the
government's chaos to be levelling up in
education
[Applause]
the honorable lady will have heard my my
honorable friend the secretary of state
extend the time scale for uh t levels
during the second reading of the skills
build uh t levels i'm sure that the
honorable lady herself would have
benefited from being able to do a t
level when she was at school it would
have given her nine weeks of work
placement she'd have done a
qualification that was designed with
employers and it would have led to a job
in the economy
dr julian
thank you mr speaker given that section
406 1b
of the
1996 education act
already outlaws quotes
the promotion of partisan political
views in the teaching of any subject in
the school
will the government without further
delay take appropriate action against
brighton and hove city council which is
planning to indoctrinate seven-year-olds
with critical race theory
well my honorable friend the most of her
qualities have been very clear that
critical race series should never be
taught as that it is a contentious
political uh viewpoint and we are
absolutely working on making sure we
update our guidance on political
impartiality for school to make that
absolutely clear
christian muslims mr speaker upton high
and my constituency is rated good with
an outstanding sick form but it keeps
getting overlooked replacement of its
1960s prefab buildings which are falling
apart when is the government government
going to announce the new uh guidelines
and will they look kindly on up to heist
application
i know the honourable gentleman recently
met with my noble friend the minister
for the school system discussed the case
for this school cheshire west and
chester council received 4.6 million in
school condition allocations this
financial year our school rebuilding
program will deliver 500 projects over
the next decade transforming education
for thousands of pupils and he has made
his case once again ben bradlee
speaker i welcome the government's
entitlement to lifelong learning and
commitment to uh level three
qualifications but my own friend the
skills minister will know many residents
around the country will need significant
help with levels one and two in order to
be able to access that offer would you
meet with representatives of west hawks
college or myself to discuss how we made
it might be able to offer that support
to people in mansfield melista i'd be
delighted to meet with my honorable
friend we are reforming level 2
qualifications and obviously the
chancellor announced our plans to
multiply a new project to help people
with numeracy of all ages
thank you very much mr speaker primary
schools and secondary schools alike are
telling me that the biggest challenge
they face is covered related staff
absence anywhere between 15 and 20 of
school staff missing can the minister
confirm how many volunteers have signed
up to the teacher volunteer drive and
what are we doing to keep teachers in
school so that we can keep them safe
of course the government's guidelines
and and guidance around kobe are very
much about keeping both staff and pupils
safe but with regard to the point you
raised about volunteers we published
figures at the beginning of january
which show that at that point the
responses from about a quarter of the
supply agencies show that 585 teachers
had come forward in answer to that call
to arms we expected the full number to
be significantly higher
into the latest dead inspection ratings
only 55 of derbyshire secondary schools
are rated good or better compared to a
national benchmark of 80
if levelling up is going to mean
anything it must be about fixing this
glaring educational inequality will the
minister agree to meet with me and
fellow derbyshire mps to discuss how we
can improve educational standards and
opportunity for all industries
certainly be happy to do that
bill coyle
thank you mr speaker the chatty mum's
network of burmese rodheid recently met
with me to raise concerns about cost of
living and lack of affordable child care
so what assessment of ministers made of
the impact of cuts to universal credit
and the new tory tax on working mums
from april
mr speaker there is a substantial offer
in place to support parents with child
care costs in 2021 328 700 children had
a government government-funded early
education entitlement place for 30 hours
worth up to 6 000 pounds
mr speaker before christmas detectives
made a statement about the tragic deaths
of arthur lavinia hughes and star hopson
to that grisly list has now been added
amigos
uh johnson he announced a review by the
serious case review national panel when
will that review be published and can he
assure us that it will be published in
full
ashley john baptiste shared his personal
story in the bbc documentary split up in
care life without siblings
his story is not unusual nor is it a
past feature of our care system
thousands of children removed from their
families alone and scared are denied
relationships with their siblings
despite all of the evidence shown this
relationship and bond is one of the most
significant in enduring so why is it
this government stubbornly refuses to
make changes to the children act and
give sibling contact
thank you very much mr speaker
mr speaker with your permission i would
like to make a statement and first i
want to express my deepest gratitude to
sue gray and all the people who have
contributed
to this report which i've placed in the
library of this house and which the
government has published in full today
for everyone to read
i will address its findings in this
statement
but firstly i want to say
sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
and it's no use
saying that this or that was within the
rules and it's no use saying that people
were working hard
[Applause]
this pandemic
was hard for everyone
we asked people across this country to
make the most extraordinary sacrifices
not to meet loved ones not to visit
relatives before they died and i
understand the anger that people feel
but mr speaker it isn't enough
to say sorry
this is a moment when let's look at
ourselves
in the mirror
and we must learn
and while the metropolitan police must
yet complete their investigation
and that means there are no details of
specific events in sue grey's report
i of course accept
sue grey's general findings in full
and above all her recommendation that we
must learn from these events and act now
with respect to the events under police
investigation she says and i quote
no conclusions should be drawn or
inferences made from this other than it
is now for the police to consider the
relevant material in relation to those
incidents but more broadly
she finds that there is significant
learning to be drawn from these events
which must be addressed immediately
across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigations to be concluded
that is why
we are making changes now
to the way downing street and the
cabinet office run
so that we can get on with the job the
job i was elected to do mr speaker and
the job that this government was elected
to do
first it is time to sort out what sue
grey rightly calls the fragmented and
complicated leadership structures of
downing street which she says have not
evolved sufficiently
to meet the demands of the expansion of
number ten
and we will do that including by
creating an office of the prime minister
with a permanent secretary to lead
number 10
second mr speaker it is clear from sue
gray's report
that it is time not just to
review the civil service and special
advisor codes
of conduct wherever necessary
to ensure that they take account of sue
gray's recommendations
but also to make sure that those codes
are properly enforced
and third i will be saying more in the
coming days
about the steps we will take to improve
the number 10 operation
and the work of the cabinet office
to strengthen
cabinet government
and to improve the vital connection
between
number 10
and parliament
mr speaker
i get it and i will fix it
and i want to say
and i want to say
to the people of this country
i know
what the issue is
yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted yes we can be trusted to deliver
we said that we would get brexit done mr
speaker and we did
and we're setting up free ports around
the whole united kingdom i've been to
one of them today which is creating tens
of thousands of new jobs mr speaker we
said we would get this country through
covet and we did we delivered the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe and
the fastest booster program of any major
economy
so that we've been able to restore
people's freedoms faster than any
comparable economy
and at the same time we've been cutting
crime by 14 percent building
new hospitals and rolling out gigabit
broadband mr speaker and delivering all
the promises of our 2019 agenda so that
we have the fastest economic growth of
the g7 we have shown that we have done
things that people thought were
impossible mr speaker and
and that we can deliver for the british
people mr speaker
i just i remind the adventures opposite
the reason we're coming out of kobit so
fast is at least partly because we
doubled the speed of the booster rollout
and i can tell the house and this
country
that we are going to bring the same
energy and commitment to getting on with
the job
to delivering for the british people and
to our mission to unite and level up
across this country mr speaker and i
commend this statement to the house
i know kirsten i'm the leader of the
opposition
uh thank you mr speaker i'd like to
thank sue gray for the diligence and
professionalism with which she's carried
out her work it's no fault of hers that
she's only been able to produce an
update today not the full report
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know that 12 cases have
reached the threshold for criminal
investigation
which i remind the house means that
there is evidence of serious and
flagrant breaches of lockdown
including including the party on the
20th of may 2020 which we know the prime
minister attended
and the party on the 13th of november
2020 in the prime minister's flat
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
the prime minister must keep his promise
to publish sue grey's report in full
when it is available
but it is already clear that the report
discloses the most damning conclusion
possible
over the last two years the british
public have been asked to make the most
heart-wrenching sacrifices
a collective trauma
endured by all
enjoyed by none
funerals have been missed
dying relatives unvisited
every family has been marked by what
we've been through
and revelations about the promised
behavior have forced us all to rethink
and relive those darkest moments
many have been overcome by rage
by grief
and even guilt
guilt
that because they stuck to the law they
did not see their parents one last time
guilt that because they didn't bend the
rules
their children went months without
seeing friends
guilt that because they did as they were
asked they didn't go and visit lonely
relatives
but people shouldn't feel guilty
they should feel pride
in themselves and their country
because by abiding by those rules
they've saved the lives of people they
will probably never meet
they have shown the deep public spirit
and the love and respect for others that
has always characterized this nation at
its best
our national story about covert is one
of the people that stood up when they
were tested
but that will be forever tainted by the
behavior of this conservative prime
minister
[Music]
by routinely breaking the rules he set
the prime minister took us all for fools
he held people sacrificing contempt he
showed himself unfit for office
his desperate denials since he was
exposed have only made matters worse
rather than come clean every step of the
way he's insulted the public's
intelligence
and now he's finally fallen back on his
usual excuse
it's everybody's fault but he is
they go
he stays
even now he is hiding behind a police
investigation into criminality into his
home and his office
mr speaker he gleefully treats what
should be a mark of shame as a welcome
shield
but prime minister the british public
aren't fools they never believed a word
of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
[Applause]
of course he won't
because he is a man without shame
and just as he has done throughout his
life he's damaged everyone and
everything around him along the way
his colleagues have spent weeks
defending the indefensible
touring the tv studios parroting his
absurd denials degrading themselves and
their offices
fraying the bond of trust between the
government oh
of south ripple is my neighbor i expect
better from my neighbours
fraying the bond of trust between the
government and the public eroding our
democracy and the rule of law
margaret thatcher once said
the first duty of government is to
uphold the law
if it tries to bob and weave and duck
around that duty when it's inconvenient
then so will the governed
mr speaker
to govern this country is an honor
not a birthright
it is an act of service to the british
people not the keys to a court to parade
to your friends
it requires honesty integrity and moral
authority
i can't tell you how many times people
have said to me that this prime
minister's lack of integrity is somehow
priced in that his behavior and
character don't matter
i have never accepted that and i never
will accept that
whatever your politics whichever party
you vote for honesty and decency matters
our great democracy depends on it
and cherishing and nurturing british
democracy is what it means to be
patriotic
there are members opposite who know that
and they know the prime minister is
incapable of it
the question they must now ask
themselves is what are they going to do
about it
[Music]
they can heap their reputations the
reputation of their party the reputation
of this country on the bonfire that is
his leadership
or they can spare the country from a
prime minister totally unworthy of his
responsibilities
[Applause]
it is their duty to do so
they know better than anyone how
unsuitable he is for high office
many of them knew in their hearts that
we would inevitably come to this one day
and they know that as night follows day
continuing his leadership will mean
further misconduct cover-up and deceit
it is only they that can end this fast
the eyes of the country are upon them
they will be judged by the decisions
they take now
hi molester
well mr speaker
there's a reason why he said absolutely
nothing about the report
that was presented uh by this government
and later put in the library of the
house earlier on say that is because mr
speaker the report does absolutely
nothing to substantiate the tissue of
nonsense and he has just spoken
absolutely absolutely instead mr speaker
this this leader of the opposition a
former director of public prosecutions
mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile as far as i can make out mr
speaker
he mr speaker chose to use it chose to
use this moment to use this moment mr
speaker continually to pre-judge a
police inquiry that's what he chose to
do
he's reached his conclusions about it
i'm not going to reach any conclusions
and he would be entirely and entirely
wrong to do so and and i direct him
again mr speaker to what uh sue gray
says in her in her report about the
conclusions that can be drawn uh from uh
her inquiry about what the police may or
may not do now mr speaker i have
complete confidence in the police and i
hope that they will uh they will be
allowed simply to get on with their job
and i don't propose to offer any more
commentary about it and i don't believe
that he should either and i must say to
him uh that what i think that and well i
think the country with greatest respect
to the ventures opposite what i think
the country wants us all in this house
to focus on
is the issues that matter to them
and getting on getting on mr speaker
we're taking this country forward and
and mr speaker uh
today uh we have delivered yet more
brexit freedom to the new freeport uh in
tilbury as i said when he voted 48 times
to take this country back into the uh to
the eu
mr speaker we have the most open society
most open economy
mr speaker this is i think what people
want us to focus on we are the most open
society most open economy in europe
because of the vaccine rollout because
of the booster relief and never forget
mr speaker that he voted uh he voted to
keep us in the european medicine agency
which would make that impossible and
today mr speaker we are standing
together with our nato allies against
the potential aggression of vladimir
putin when he wanted not so long ago to
install a prime minister as prime
minister a labour leader who would
actually have abolished nato mr speaker
that's what he believes in those are his
priorities well i can say to him he can
continue with his political opportunism
we are going to get on and i am going to
get on with the job
[Applause]
quiet
theresa may thank you mr speaker
the coverage regulations impose
significant restrictions on the freedoms
of members of the public
they had a right to expect their prime
minister
to have read the rules to understand the
meaning of the rules and indeed those
around them to have done around him to
have done so too
and to set an example in following those
rules
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
[Applause]
it's a very important question i want to
hear the answer even if other people go
prime minister
no mr speaker that is not what the uh
grey report says
[Music]
i
suggest that you wait to see uh the
conclusion of the inquiry
i now come to the leader of the smp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i say it's a
pleasure to follow the
former prime minister and perhaps
her behavior in office like many that
went before him was about dignity about
the importance of the office of respect
of truthfulness and the prime minister
we were well advised to focus on those
that have not dishonored the office like
he has done
mr speaker
we stand here today
faced with the systematic decimation of
public trust in government and the
institutions of the state
and at its heart
a prime minister
a prime minister
being investigated
by the police
so here we have it the long-awaited sue
grey report what a farce
it was
carefully engineered to be
a fact-finding exercise
with no conclusions
now we find
it's a fact-finding exercise
with no facts
so
let's talk facts
the prime minister has told the house
that
all guidance was completely followed
there was no party
covered rules were followed in that
i believed it was a work event
nobody
nobody believed them then
and nobody
nobody believes you now prime minister
[Music]
that is the crux
no ifs no buts
he has willfully willfully misled
parliament
it's bad enough oh oh
order
prime minister inadvertently told the
house in the 8th of december that no
parties had taken place and then had to
admit that they had
it's bad enough mr speaker that the
prime minister's personal integrity is
in the ditch
but this murky business is tainting
everything around it
it is our in
to submit our ocean
instructing the prime minister to
publish the great report in full
well the prime minister
of being instruction by this house to
publish as required
mr speaker
amidst allegations of blackmail by tory
wips
the members opposite have been defending
the indefensible
wait for the report we were told
well here it is
and it tells us very little except it
does state
that there were failures of leadership
and judgment by different parts of
number 10. it states that some events
should not have been allowed to take
place
that is the prime minister's
responsibility
if there is any honour
any honor in public life
then he would resign
where is this
and the prime minister laughs
we ought to remind ourselves in this
house
and 150 000 plus of our citizens have
lost their lives
family members that couldn't be with
them and that is the site that people
will remember a prime minister laughing
at our public i extend the hand of
friendship
to all those that have sacrificed i
certainly do not extend the hand of
friendship to the prime minister who is
no friend of mine
where is the shame
where is the dignity
meanwhile the police investigation will
drag on and on
every moment the prime minister stays
trust in government and the rule of law
is ebbing away the litany of rule
breaking the culture of contempt the
utter disdain for the anguish felt by
the public who have sacrificed so much
what the public see
is a man who has debased the office of
prime minister shrinked responsibility
dogged accountability and blamed his
staff at every turn presiding over and
corruption and tainted the very
institutions of the state in short mr
speaker this is a man
[Applause]
well they can laugh
they can laugh
but the public know
the public know this is a man they can
no longer trust
he has been investigated by the police
he misled the house he must now resign
honor
you'll have to withdraw that last
comment
mr speaker i gave the evidence of the
8th of december
you're going to have to withdraw misled
mr speaker the prime minister has misled
her
[Applause]
unless you withdraw i will have to stop
and that's not good just withdraw the
words
i am standing up for my constituents
that know that this prime minister has
lied and misled the house
[Applause]
i'll give you one more chance as leader
of the snp i don't want to throw you out
i'm going to give you this chance please
feast the power that man has left out
the house
shut up
i'm sorry it's come to this
and i'm sorry the leader of the party
has not got the decency just withdraw
those words in order that this debate
can be represented by all political
leaders
would you like to inadvertently
speak if the prime minister has
inadvertently misled the house then i
will state that
right we're going to leave it at that
nine minutes sir
mr speaker i
i'm
grateful to the uh right on the
withdrawing uh what he just said because
he was wrong then and uh
he i'm afraid is wrong in the in his
analysis and i i i apologize as i've
said for uh all the suffering that
people have had throughout this pandemic
and
for the anger that people feel
about uh what has taken place in in
number 10 down the street but i've got
i've got to tell
the uh the right honourable gentleman
that for much of what he said his best
course is simply to wait for the uh for
the inquiry to be completed
can i just say i take it the honourable
member that's withdrawn the right to
remember
that the prime minister may have
inadvertently misled the house
to help me to help the house you
withdraw your early comments and replace
it with inadvertently it's not my fault
if the prime minister can't be trusted
[Applause]
under the power given to me by standing
order number 43 i ordered the honorable
member to withdraw immediately from the
house
[Applause]
it's all right we don't need to bother
right let us move on andrew mitchell
does my right honourable friend recall
that uh ever since he joined the party's
candidates list 30 years ago
until we got him into number 10 he has
enjoyed
my full-throated support
but i am deeply concerned by these
events and i'm very concerned indeed by
some of the things he has said from that
dispatch book
and has said to the british public and
our constituents
when he kindly invited me to see him 10
days ago i told him that i thought he
should think very carefully about what
was now in the best interest of our
country and on the conservative party
and i have to tell him he no longer
enjoys my support
well uh
mr speaker i i must tell respectfully uh
my right honourable friend great though
uh the admiration uh is that i have of
him i i simply think that he's uh
mistaken in his views and uh i urge him
to i urge him to to reconsider upon full
consideration of the of the inquiry
dear manchester united
thank you very much uh mr speaker
the prime minister
told us and i'm quoting him i have
repeatedly been assured since these
allegations emerged
that there was no party and that no
covert rules were broken
we now know that
12 of the 16 parties are subject to a
police investigation
and that of the remaining four
the sue grey report says this that she's
seen a serious failure to observe the
high standards at number ten she's seen
failures of leadership
failures of judgment
and
the prime minister thinks this is fine
so just how bad do things have to be
before he takes personal responsibility
does what everybody in this country
wants him to do and resign
mr speaker what we are doing is taking
the action that i've described uh to set
up a prime minister's department to
improve the operation of number 10 and
we will be taking further steps mr
speaker in uh in the days ahead
remember
speaker the
uh inquiry has found there have been
serious failings and has suggested
there'll be changes in the uh the way
that uh number 10 is run and there's a
real opportunity now to take forward
this new office of the prime minister
and ensure further improvements are made
so that we can carry on delivering
because what the party's opposite hate
is the fact that this government will
carry on delivering on the things that
matter most to people while also making
sure that the government's within number
10 is improved
i thank my right on my friend very very
much i think he's completely right i do
think that
the opposition of course i want to keep
the uh their focus trained on this
that's that's their decision i think mr
speaker i think mr speaker what the
people this country want us to do is to
get on with the job that they want us to
do and that is to serve them mr speaker
and to stop talking frankly about
ourselves
[Applause]
mr speaker there is no word in the
english language
for a parent who has lost a child
no equivalent of widow or orphan for
that particular horror
it is a loss that is literally beyond
words
a loss that hundreds and thousands of
parents
have tragically experienced during this
pandemic
many had to bury their children alone
many couldn't be there with them at the
end
meanwhile
number 10 parted
does the prime minister understand
does he care about the enormous hurt his
actions have caused to bereave families
across our country
will he finally accept
that the only decent thing that he can
do now
is to resign
mr speaker i do
care deeply about the hurt that is felt
across the country uh about the
suggestion that uh things were going on
in number ten that were in contravention
of the of the kobe rules and i
understand how deeply people feel about
this and how angry
that they are and and i and i've
apologized uh several times mr speaker
but i must say that i think we should
wait for the outcome of the inquiry by
before jumping to the conclusions uh
that he has and in the meantime we
should focus on the issues that matter
to the british people
caroline notes
speaker the public in this house have
been frustrated by having to wait for
sue gray wait for the metropolitan
police and today the prime minister has
announced his new office at number 10.
please can you let this house know what
specific structures are going to be put
in place
so that this house can hold it
accountable
uh well mr speaker we will make sure
that there's a new permanent secretary
uh to who will be accountable uh to me
uh and we will make sure that the codes
of conduct that are applied both to
spads and to uh civil servants are
properly enforced and of course uh all
of that will be properly communicated to
that to the house mr speaker and what i
want to see is much better communication
and uh and links between a number 10 and
the entirety of the house of commons and
we will do that so george howarth
yeah
thank you mr speaker yesterday
at the local
tesco store in my constituency
a constituents asked me it an atone more
in sorrow than in anger
why doesn't the prime minister realize
that as every day goes by
he damages the reputation of our country
and
abroad and around the world
why he said doesn't the prime minister
realize that how would he respond to
that constitution
mr speaker i think the reputation of our
country around the world is built on the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe
economies uh it is built on having the
fastest growth therefore in the g7 and
it is built on our ability to bring
bring our allies together to stand up
against vladimir putin that is what the
world is focused on that is what i am
focused on and that frankly is what he
should be focused on
thank you uh mr speaker can my right
honourable friend first of all
uh remind the leader of the opposition
in the labour party that the
backbenchers of the conservative party
need no reminders about how to dispose
of a failing leader
[Music]
and can he
can he
can he also
can he also when he is restructuring
number 10
concentrate on the fact that the country
wants results
the country we can't see the point of
such a large number 10 superstructure
that it needs to be slimmed down and
streamlined and can i commend his
determination to restore
to restore cabinet to restore cabinet
government and it is on results over the
next few months on which he will be
judged
uh well mr speaker i thank my friend
very much for that and i i think he's
entirely right and i'm
more than content to be judged mr
speaker on the results that we've
already delivered in the results that we
will deliver i'm sure that we'll be
greatly assisted by the reforms of
number 10 of the liver line diane abbott
thank you mr speaker
anybody who's actually read the supreme
report
can only wonder
what she was made to leave out
will the prime minister give the house
an undertaking that as soon as he is
able he will release the full
unredacted report to this house
mr speaker sue gray has published
everything uh that she can and i propose
that we wait until the conclusion of the
of the inquiry but in the meantime mr
speaker i think it uh i think peculiar
that the report is being simultaneously
uh hailed as utterly damning uh but also
uh condemned for not uh having enough in
it uh this is the economy it can't be
both
vital fabrication president truman had
on his desk the buck stops here
so the prime minister was right to
apologize for the events that happened
in number 10 downing street
two weeks ago
i reminded tom harwood that tony blair
suggested that there should be an office
of prime minister so that it could be
governed not from 70 whitehall but from
the building itself
could the prime minister tell me how he
envisions the office will work will the
permanent secretary be based in number
10 controlling what civil servants do in
number 10.
i i'm grateful to my honourable friend
uh very grateful i think the house does
understand even if many people outside
uh don't the number 10 actually uh
hosts about more than 400 officials uh
on on a busy day they have a huge amount
uh to do and and we need to make sure we
need to make sure
no mr speaker they're working very hard
that's what they're doing
and and we need to make sure uh that
there are proper lines of authority and
that we sort out the the command
structures and that's what we're doing
overlaps
thank you mr speaker
whatever the police decide this uh
updates severely limited as it is would
be enough to persuade any other prime
minister to resign
this prime minister could resign and
salvage salvage for himself a come or
two of honour or he may try to dismay to
delay and take his party down with him
so mr speaker is it not clear
that's with notable exceptions
his backbenchers should discover their
backbones and sucking
mr speaker i've answered several
questions like that and i just i must
really ask him to look at the uh report
properly and also to wait uh for the
inquiry when it comes i'll calper
thank you very much um mr speaker
we've been asked to keep some sense of
perspective and i think that's right
the question here
is whether those who make the law obey
the law that's pretty fundamental um
many have questioned including some of
my constituents the prime minister's
honesty and integrity and fitness to
hold that office now in judging him he
rightly asked us
to wait for all the facts sue gray has
made it clear in her update today that
she couldn't produce a meaningful report
with the fans so can i ask the prime
minister the question that the
honourable lady the member for hackney
north and stoke newington asked him into
which he didn't give an answer when sue
gray produces
all of the facts
in her full report after the police
investigation will he commit
to publish it immediately
and in full yeah
[Applause]
mr speaker what we've got to do
is
wait for the
wait for the wait i wait for the police
to conclude their enquiries mr speaker
that is the proper thing to do people
have given uh all sorts of evidence and
the expectation that it would not
necessarily uh be published mr speaker
uh at that stage i will take a decision
about what the publishers
thank you mr speaker um i imagine that
i'm going to be asked to wait for
something else
um but can i just simply ask the prime
minister
was the prime minister present at the
event in his flat
on the 13th of november i assume he
doesn't need other people to tell him
whether he was there or not
um was he at the flat event listed in
the report on the 13th of november
mr speaker i'm very grateful to the uh
honorable lady for inviting me to to
comment on something that is
being investigated
with great respect to her i am certainly
not going to indulge in running comedy
she will have to wait mr speaker
sir
mr
speaker
saying
sorry is very
important but my right honourable friend
will be judged by the deeds that he
undertakes as a result i heard today
a proper acknowledgement that he needs
to look in the mirror
and i'm glad to hear about reforms to
the center of government that i think
are timely in fact they're over due as
he knows from previous conversations
i've had with him but will he give me
and the house this undertaking today
that in cooperating with the
metropolitan police inquiry he will show
uh the appropriate tone and approach
that i think the british public demand
of him
as as a person of serious purpose who is
up to the level of events that's what we
expect from him now and that's what i'll
be expecting him to do
i i thank my writer and friend very much
and i just want to stress mr speaker
that i i have great admiration for the
metropolitan police and full confidence
in the police and i i i just suggested
that they'd be allowed now to get on
with their job
well
thank you mr speaker we now know
that there's a criminal investigation
into the party that took place on the
13th of november
2020
in his flat
to celebrate the exit of mr cummings
on the 8th of december last year
he came to that dispatch box
and flatly denied
the very idea that any
such party had taken places shaking his
head in answer to my honourable friend
the member for hornsey and wood green
he said it had not happened
now it's inadvertently mr speaker
misled the house
so the very least he should do is get to
that dispatch box
and correct
the record
no mr speaker i stand by what i said and
i would urge and i would simply urge him
i would simply urge him to wait for the
outcome of the inquiry that's what he
needs to do
dr julian lewis
thank you mr speaker
may i advise my right honourable friend
publicly
what i have said to emissaries from his
campaign team privately
that it is truly in his interest
in the government's interest and in the
national interest that he should insist
on receiving the full
unredacted report immediately as i
believe he can and that he should then
publish the uncensored version without
any further delay
i'm very grateful to my right honourable
friend but i think extensive legal
advice has been taken uh on this point
and uh sue gray has published everything
that she thinks she can that is
consistent with that advice
mr speaker and if the police
investigation were to result in serious
criminal charges
necessitating a criminal trial such as i
don't know for example misconduct in
public office
or conspiracy to pervert the course of
justice
how would the prime minister feel about
having to give evidence on oath
obviously i'm not going to speculate
about
hypothetical uh
uh
uh questions which which frankly i
reject thank you well fred job
mr speaker you all know that it's a very
rare event for any prime minister to
come to this house and apologize it's
a difficult thing for any prime minister
to do
but on the issue of the police
investigation does my right honourable
friend agree with me that there should
be due process that there should be free
and unfettered access to all at number
10 but most of all there should be no
pre-judging or undermining of the police
inquiry before it's concluded
[Music]
yes i i completely agree and i must say
i'm shocked by some of the commentary
that i've heard uh from the benches
opposite about that matter today mr
speaker
chris brown
thank you mr speaker the thing is
this is who the prime minister is
a serious failure to observe high
standards
failures of leadership and judgment
excessive consumption of alcohol in a
professional workplace gatherings that
shouldn't not have been able to take
place staff too frightened to raise
concerns parties in his own private flat
a leopard doesn't change its spots
does it
every single one who defends this
will face this again
and again
and again
because he still won't even admit to the
house that when he came to us
on the 13th of november and said the
guidance and the rules were followed at
all times and on the 1st of december
that all the guidelines were observed
that those things simply were not true
if you won't
correct the record today
there's
nothing accidental about this is there
it's deliberate
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know what he's
trying to say mr speaker but
look look
i direct him again to the uh point made
by sue gray uh that no conclusions
should be drawn or inferences made uh
from this other than it is now time for
the police to consider the relevant
material and that is what the house
should allow them frankly to do
shallow
it is absolutely right that over the
past few weeks
our constituents across the house
have been writing to us on this hugely
important issue
and i don't in any way wish to minimize
its importance
but in my constituency i have military
bases
and i am receiving emails from families
who are concerned about their loved ones
and the potential role they may end up
playing given the conflict on the
russian ukrainian border
members opposite may
treat this lightly but for the families
but families who have those serving the
military do not treat it lightly
would my right honourable friend
give me an assurance
that notwithstanding the importance of
the issue that we are discussing at
present his government will start
addressing other important matters that
concern my constituents and the
constituents of people across this house
thank you very much indeed and i think
he's completely right that the of course
these matters are important we've got to
wait for the uh for the inquiry but in
the meantime the uk has got to play uh
the leading role that we are mr speaker
in bringing the west together to make a
united front against vladimir putin
particularly with the economic sanctions
that we need mr speaker that is uh the
priority of the government right now
colin baseman
mr speaker while the prime minister was
eating birthday cake with his pals
people were standing outside nursing
home windows looking in at their loved
ones dying and contrary to what the
prime minister has said from that very
dispatch spots multiple times any
objective reading of sue gray's update
makes it absolutely clear that the rules
were broken multiple times in downing
street will the prime minister continue
a habit of a lifetime and keep blaming
everybody else or will he finally stand
up take responsibility and just go
[Music]
uh mr speaker he's really got to read
the report and he's got it he's got to
look at the report and he's going to
he's got to wait this is all everything
he said i'm afraid is not substantiated
by the report uh he should look uh and
wait for the uh for the police inquiry
steve baker thank you mr speaker
millions of people millions of people
took seriously a communications campaign
apparently designed by behavioral
psychologists
to bully to his people
the bully twos people
who meticulously complied with all of
the rules and suffered terribly for it
including i might say those people whose
mental health
will have suffered appallingly as a
result of the messages his government
was sending out
mr speaker i want to thank all those
people uh for everything that they did
because together uh they have helped us
to control uh coronavirus and i think
thanks to their amazing actions in
coming forward uh to get vaccinated
we're now in a far better position than
many other countries around the world so
i have a massive debt of gratitude to
all the people that he describes then
diana johnson
question asked by my honourable friend
the member for birmingham yardley i'm
not asking for a running commentary but
i would like to know whether the prime
minister was present in his flat at the
event on the 13th of november 2020.
i i'm really grateful to mr speaker i
understand why people want me to
elaborate on all sorts of points but i
am not going to make a running
commentary on a matter that is now being
uh considered uh by the authorities i've
got to wait for them to conclude
andrew jones mr speaker the update that
we have from sue grey today is as she
says herself extremely limited and that
it is not possible at present to provide
a meaningful report so will my righteous
friend confirm that the earliest
opportunity he will have the report
published in fall
oh mr speaker what we will do is uh wait
until the police have concluded uh their
enquiries and then see what more uh we
can publish that is what we are going to
do
west
thank you very much mr speaker as the
prime minister will recall on the eighth
of december in primary prime minister's
questions i asked him
was there a party in downing street on
the 13th of november
and now the report says in the bullet
point on the first page that there was a
gathering in the number 10 downing
street flat
gathering in the number 10 downing
street on the departure of a special
adviser
did he
inadvertently mislead this house put us
all out of our agony and stop dragging
democracy through the mud
mr speaker
i stick by what i said to her and she
should wait uh if she cares about
democracy and due process she should
wait until until the inquiry has been
concluded
thank you mr speaker as a non-drinker
who long ago realized that sobriety
delivers everything that alcohol
promised i've noticed with interest
that a drinking culture exists in
downing street and in fact predates my
right honourable friend's tenure by some
decades
does he
like me welcome sue grey's report and
will he commit to fixing that culture
yes mr speaker i thank you very much and
uh we're certainly mr speaker going to
take up uh the relevant parts of her
recommendations and see that they're
properly enforced in the civil service
and this bad code
thank you very much mr speaker the
shocking incompetence of the met police
has meant that we have a report that has
been gutted but frankly we didn't need
sue grey to tell us about the level of
dishonor and deception that is infected
not only downing street but so many in
the party opposite it has been
excruciating to watch so many tory mps
and ministers willing to defend the
indefensible calculating what's in their
own party political interests rather
than what's right for our country
complicit in the same decaying system
where the pursuit of power trumps
integrity
the prime minister is certainly a bad
apple but the whole tree is rotten and
the whole country wants reform
couldn't we make a start with a major
overhaul of the ministerial code given
that its founding assumption that it
could be policed by a prime minister of
the day because they would be a person
of honesty and integrity
that founding assumption has been so
widely and comprehensively and utterly
discredited
[Music]
uh mr speaker uh of all the things that
she just we are we are reforming the
ministerial code but of all the things
that i disagree with her
about what she's just said i disagree
with her most passionately in what she's
just said about the police i think they
do an outstanding job i think we should
allow them to get on with that job and i
will await their conclusions okay doyle
price thank you mr speaker if i just uh
draw attention to finding number seven
uh in this report which documents that
actually number ten downstream has
morphed from a small team in support of
the prime minister to a self-indulgent
bureaucracy all its own and i personally
am tired of reading sunday newspapers
which read on officials briefing against
ministers delays by things being stuck
in the potentials i speak to ministers
who are getting frustrated so
could i ask my out of a friend that as
he institutes this review call me
old-fashioned but ministers are
accountable for decisions and that they
take taken in their name not flunkies in
number 10 and will he ensure that
reforms properly restore ministerial
accountability yes
i i thank her very much and i very much
enjoyed our joint trip to uh tilbury uh
this morning and i can tell her that yes
i do think that it's vital as sue grace
says that we learn from this and that we
strengthen a cabinet government and the
principle of ministerial uh
responsibility
uh thank you mr speaker
i have spoken about my own experience of
loss during the pandemic many times
i do not claim that my experience are
special
indeed they were all too common
but as a member of parliament i have a
responsibility to provide a voice for
the briefed families
make no mistake
this report is utterly damning and
suggests that the prime ministers and
the government's actions were a risk to
public health
how on earth can the prime minister
stand there and justify this
does he now accept that his actions were
a complete and absolute failure of
leadership and judgment
mr speaker i thank him very much i
repeat what i've said that i am deeply
sorry for all the suffering there's been
uh throughout this pandemic whether of
his constituents or anyone uh in the in
the country as to his his points about
uh what is in the report i don't think
his views are substantiated by the uh by
what the report says but i think he
should wait he should wait to see uh
where the inquiry goes and that's what i
propose to do
somewhere
thank you mr speaker does my right hand
agree with me that those opposites have
used far too much time far too much
parliamentary time debating this and i
can assure my right and we're friends
that the residents of starbridge the
residents established they want the
prime minister to focus on the matters
that really they care about
just just a moment
in furnace the prime minister has to
come and make the statement no i'm not
going to attack the prime minister we're
making a statement i certainly wouldn't
expect from his own side
thank you mr speaker i think possibly
what my and i want to say how strongly i
agree with my uh nonetheless with my my
honourable friend because uh because yes
of course uh it's it's vital that we
make this statement yes of course it's
vital that we uh learn from sue gray's
report vital that we take action uh mr
speaker which is what the government is
doing but it's also vital frankly that
we get on with the people's priorities
and that is what this government is also
doing christian mapleson thank you mr
speaker so just to summarize we've had i
didn't know there was a party um there
wasn't the party but it was a work
meeting um and um there was a party but
um i wasn't there um
why is it the prime minister mentioned
um international negotiations why should
anybody any country any government with
whom we enter into negotiations deals
at all and take take um any kind of uh
word from a government that clearly acts
with mendacity of force that forethought
from start to beginning
uh well mr speaker uh this is the
government that took this country out of
the eu uh did what was necessary and
this is the government uh that is
bringing uh the west together to stand
up against vladimir putin and those
those are the those are the important
considerations as for the rest of what
he said mr speaker it's nonsense but he
should wait for the police inquiry bobby
croft
speaker my constituents in scotland are
very keen to see the industrial energy
crisis fixed will the prime minister
reassure me that he will not be
distracted by any of this and that he
will get on with the job and come
comforted a solution to that issue
yes i think my honourable friend is
completely right we not only need to
address uh consumer energy costs we need
to address uh address business and
industrial energy costs as well and i
know that uh my rather friend uh the
chancellor uh is will be bringing
forward a package of measures as soon as
he can
custodial
mr speaker during his statement the
prime minister kept referring to we
when he talks about the sorry saga that
sue green has reported
but mr speaker it's his rules it's his
rule-breaking it's his inability to tell
the truth about it that's the issue he's
the prime minister does he not take any
personal responsibility at all for this
disgraceful fiasco
mr speaker i've taken full
responsibility throughout the pandemic
richard fuller
speaker as with the report on owen
patterson i thought it was important to
support the process
and read the report
and that's because i think it's
important to separate fact from
allegation
and to know what the report actually
says rather than what i would wish it to
say
two lessons that the leader of the
opposition needs to learn
i promised my constituents that i would
ask the prime minister to say that he
would support the recommendations in the
report there are four that every
government department has a clear and
robust policy in place covering the
consumption of alcohol in the workplace
that access to the garden including for
meetings should be invitation only and a
controlled environment but there should
be easier ways for staff to raise such
concerns basically whistleblowing and
that too much responsibility and
expectation is placed on the senior
official whose principal function is the
direct support of the prime minister
those are the facts and the findings of
the report will the prime minister
accept
yeah yes uh yes mr speaker i i do and as
i said to the house earlier on i accept
the findings of the report uh in full uh
the general findings and uh we are
immediately taking steps to implement
the changes
the prime minister's just said he
accepts the findings of the report
one of them
says that there were failures of
leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 the cabinet office at
different times
he provides the political leadership and
the political judgment and number 10
does he accept his own personal
wrongdoing and failings in this regard
mr speaker not only have i accepted full
responsibility uh throughout uh but i i
have apologized repeatedly to the house
for any misjudgments that i may have
made myself but again i must urge her to
wait for the conclusion of the inquiry
erin bell
it seems a lot of people attended events
in may 2020 the one i recall attending
was my grandmother's funeral she was a
wonderful woman as well as a love for
her family she served her community as a
counsellor and she served art for
conservative association loyally for
many years i drove for three hours from
staffordshire to kent
only 10 people at the funeral many
people who loved it i had to watch
online i didn't hug my siblings i didn't
hug my parents i gave a eulogy and then
afterwards i didn't even go to her house
for a cup of tea i drove back three
hours from kent to staffordshire does
the prime minister think i'm a fool
no mr speaker i want to
thank my honourable friend and i want to
i i want to say how deeply i sympathize
with him uh and his family uh for their
loss uh and all i can say is
again that
i'm very very sorry for this judgments
that may be made in uh by me or anybody
else in number 10
and the cabinet office and i i can only
ask him respectfully uh mr speaker to
look at what sue gray has said but also
to look at the to wait for the
conclusion of the inquiry
thank you mr speaker it's important that
this house can trust what ministers tell
us from that dispatch box and on the 8th
of december and regarding events at
number 10 downey street the minister the
prime minister said i repeat that i've
been repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party and that no covered rules were
broken that is what i've been repeatedly
assured
now the people who gave him those
assurances
led to him inadvertently misleading the
house
so how those people faced any
disciplinary proceedings
mr speaker first of all he needs to
to i'm afraid to await the conclusions
of the police inquiry because uh he i'm
afraid that uh he the premise of his
question may not or may or may not be uh
substantiated but what i can tell the
house is yes as i've said before there's
certainly there certainly will be
changes in the way we do things and
changes in number 10.
duncan baker
speaker
north norfolk consistently had some of
the lowest levels of infection in the
country
we followed
the rules
so many of my constituents have been
incensed the damage that this is doing
to the government is enormous
it is about integrity and trust
can i ask again because people want to
know
how can the prime minister now
satisfy my constituents and assure me
that full accountability
and transparency on the findings of the
final grey report will swiftly
follow
yeah
well
mr speaker
i will do
whatever i can to ensure that this house
has as much clarity as possible there
are legal issues uh that that we face uh
mr speaker about some of the some of the
testimony that has been uh that has been
given uh but in the meantime uh what i
think
sue gray wants uh us to do is to wait
for the conclusion of the of the
investigation of the inquiry and to see
where that goes and to support the
police in their work
thank you
uh mr speaker that's the prime minister
need somebody else to tell him whether
he was there or
he is there now
i i refer the honorable the answer i've
already given time
mr speaker we all recognize that number
10 downing street is an unusual amalgam
of workplace office space and private
home what steps will the prime minister
take
um to ensure that the lines between each
of them are made clearer in the future
uh mr speaker that's
you will see that there are
a
reference to that a very problem in sue
gray's uh report and we're going to take
steps and mr speaker to uh clarify
things and to make sure uh there are
there is greater transparency in the
lines of of command
stephen james
thank you mr speaker does the prime
minister recognize that repeatedly
making statements including from that
dispatch box which turn out subsequently
to be untrue is a serious problem or
does he not recognize that
i miss mr speaker i really think he's
prejudging things and he should wait for
the conclusion of the of the inquiries
paul holmes thank you mr speaker
i welcome the fact that my writing
befriend has come to this house as a
first step in responding to this report
he's also rightly outlined that the
relationship between number 10 and this
house needs to improve so will he
reassure me that he'll continue to come
to this house to update us on the
implementation of the recommendations in
sue grey's report and how that will
happen
mr speaker i i will of course i'm only
too happy to
assure the house that we intend to uh
make changes starting from now and uh i
will keep the house updated
paula barca thank you mr speaker
when there's a failure of leadership
and an inappropriate culture in an
organisation the person at the top
should go
this outrageous debacle hasn't happened
in spite of the prime minister this has
happened because of the prime minister
will the prime minister now do the right
thing and resign
mr speaker the answer is no because i'm
going to wait for the conclusions of the
the conclusions of the inquiry uh before
before
all any of the assertions that she's
made can be established
greg smith
mr speaker i
thank the prime minister for his
statement particularly the
acknowledgement of the enormous
sacrifice that so many british people
went through and as somebody who was
unable to say goodbye to my grandparents
this time
last year
can i welcome his sincere
apology
but as we
as we wait
as we wait for the metropolitan police
findings can my right on my friend give
me a categoric assurance that it will be
full speed ahead on fixing the northern
ireland protocol standing up for our
friends in ukraine and fixing the cost
of living crisis
[Applause]
uh yes mr speaker that is exactly what
this government is going to do and
normal will be distracted for one minute
when david
thank you mr speaker in the the general
findings to secure so sue gray's report
there's a reference to the failure of
leadership and judgment by number 10.
does the prime minister accept that sue
gray was largely referring to him
yeah
mr speaker i really think that he should
uh recite the whole report but i have
told him that i accept the findings uh
i've set the findings uh that sue gray
has given in full and we are acting on
them today
speaker i am i welcome my right
honourable friend's apology he's taken
responsibility he's apologized and it's
right that he should do so
this will remain top
of the new office of the prime minister
because that's what the country wants to
see we want to see this prime minister
getting on with the job
yes that's right mr speaker and that's
why we brought forth the nationalities
and borders bill which i'm delighted to
say that she
supports that this government is getting
through
thank you the frequency of some of the
answers today and the non-answer solar
questions don't suggest the prime
minister is generally that sorry
does he recognize long-term damage he
risks doing to historic norms of
democracy is it right that they are
sacrificing the interests of one man who
refused to do what the country knows
needs to happen and can he point to one
single example where he personally has
improved standards in public life
how about mr speaker uh deciding to
honor the wishes of the people
[Music]
and deliver brexit in spite of their
attempts mr speaker to subvert democracy
rob roberts
mr speaker delivery is key
the prime minister delivers
he delivered on brexit
he delivered with furlough and with the
self-employed
scheme
that ensured businesses were able to
survive they can shout it down because
they don't like it mr speaker that's
fine
he delivered with one of the best
vaccination programs in the world
he delivered a country that is coming
out of a pandemic and an economy that is
thriving
with people who sadly lost their jobs in
the last two years having more vacancies
than ever to choose from
but nobody talks about those things mr
speaker
because all sides of those things
i think the prices may have just got a
grip of what you've had to say prime
minutes
mr speaker we're going to deliver on the
people's priorities and we're going to
deliver and keep delivering for wales
florence session though mate
thank you mr speaker mr speaker one of
the hardest things i had to do as an mp
is speak to the family of
ishmael mohammed abdulli
he was 13 years old when he died on the
30th of march he was one of the youngest
people to lose his life to covert
i will admit mr speaker when i spoke to
his mother i broke down on that call
ishmael's family like so many other
constituents up and down in vauxhall
followed the rule
many of them were scared to go out many
of them had to bury their loved ones
without being there
many of them walked past the covered
memorial wall in my constituency with
that heart showing their loss
does the prime minister now understand
and does he not feel ashamed that his
actions
have bought distribute to the office
that he holds
mr speaker of course i
uh
share the
honorable ladies grief
for ishmael uh i sympathize with
uh ishmael's family and
i i understand the pain and loss of the
everybody's experience throughout this
country uh uh but uh mr speaker all i
can say
is that i will continue to do my best to
fight kobe as i have done uh throughout
this pandemic and and to deliver for the
british people and i can't say more than
that welcome
thank you mr speaker mr speaker running
an office
having the required management expertise
of
running literally dozens and dozens of
offices with hundreds and hundreds of
people within
is one thing
running the country and getting the big
decisions right are quite another
so can i welcome the prime minister's
commitment
to have a look at what is happening at
number 10 and those management
structures so that we can deliver on the
promises and the brexit promises we gave
the people of this country
i i thank him very much and that's why
we're taking up the findings of the uh
the subreddit report we want to make
sure that number 10 uh works better that
the whole of the government works better
it's been focused very much on uh on
coded uh but we now need to deliver
exclusively on the on the great
priorities of the people
last summer my team and i said goodbye
to our colleagues through the window of
her hospice as she died of cancer we
didn't get to hug her
and we were just like many millions of
people across the uk
we followed the rules while he and his
colleagues didn't and it makes me sick
to my stomach that we are not going to
get the findings of this report because
the police were so late to the party the
same met police who were happy to arrest
women who were protesting the murder of
sarah everard and it makes me sick to my
stomach that he does not understand the
anger and fury and upset of millions of
people across the uk because sometimes
mr speaker an apology won't cut it it's
time for action it's time for a
clear-out it's time for him to resign
mr speaker i i again i i sympathize very
much with the experience of
uh her constituents uh and all the pain
that people have gone through throughout
this pandemic uh i must say to her
though that she is prejudging uh the
issue that the issue in question today i
don't think that's the right thing to do
i have a great deal of respect for the
police and i think they should be
allowed to get on with their job paul
thank you mr speaker um
i think we've got to remember that we're
all talking about the breaking of the
rules
and the rules
clearly are under question here as to
what's happened but the rules themselves
that were put out by this government
have got this country to where it is
we've got to remember that those rules
did the right thing
so yes there's got to be consequences in
number 10 for any rules that have been
broken but please remember the right
thing was done by the instigation of the
rules in the first place and i have to
say
when i'm talking to my constituents out
there they're saying yes we need to ask
the question about what's happened there
but can we stop being that there's the
only soul subject and
can the opposition talk about something
else as well please do we need to move
on and level up this country
i i thank my honourable friend very much
and i think i think he's right the rules
are important and it was very it was it
was it was amazing and remains amazing
to see the way people pulled together
throughout the the pandemic and i i
thank people very much uh but what we
need to do if we possibly can and mr
speaker if the opposition would uh
i think would would agree we now need to
focus on the issues that matter above
all to the british people fixing the
cost of living rebuilding our economy
clearing the kobe backlogs that's what
this government is doing
very sherman
speaker i have known the prime minister
a long time
and we've always got on quite well
he's not a wicked man
but he's a man that for years in every
job has got by flying on the seat of his
pants
he has a chaotic management staff
and that is a question of character
and can i ask him really to look in the
mirror as he said this morning and say
am i the man at this challenging time
for our country
abroad at home in every sense has he the
character to carry on and do that job
yes mr speaker because quite frankly i
think it was absolutely indispensable
that we had a strong number 10
that was able to take us out of the eu
in spite of all the efforts of the party
opposite uh to block it and not only
that mr speaker a booster and a vaccine
campaign that were led by number 10 that
have made a dramatic difference not just
to the health of this country but to the
economic fortunes of this country and
whatever he says about me and my
leadership that is what we have
delivered in the last year alone
scott benson you mr speaker when
knocking in doors in blackpool at the
weekend i spoke to julie who said this
this prime minister has had the most
difficult job in living history he's
been dealing with a pandemic in which he
nearly died
he's been dealing with the media who
haven't forgiven him for delivering
brexit
and yet
let's
he's been dealing with the media who
haven't forgiven him yet for dealing
with brexit and he hasn't had a chance
to crack on and deliver yet for british
people on their priorities
report today has come out the prime
minister has apologized let's allow him
to get on and do
i want to say how passionately
vehemently and emphatically i agree uh
with the remarks which i couldn't quite
hear
of my my honorable friend he is
completely right mr speaker and i think
that is the priority of the british
people that's the priority of the
government
as limited as the grey report uh was uh
we know that that the findings are still
incredibly damning
multiple
issues around failures of leadership and
judgment now given that the nolan
principles and standards of public life
describe the centrality of integrity
honesty and leadership how can the prime
minister continue
i really think that she needs to read
the report carefully mr speaker
and and and and i'm afraid that the
conclusions that she's drawing are not
ones that i support but what we are
doing mr speaker is is following sue
gray's advice and we are changing the
way number 10 runs and we are going to
uh to do things differently mr speaker
but i i can't agree uh with what she
says catherine fletcher mr speaker
on saturday i was out about enjoying ice
cream in lancashire which i know you and
your family do in some of the finest ice
cream parlors in the north of england
and they said to me
he's a wally
but a hundred thousand russians have
just turned up well and what the bloody
hell are we doing talking about cake
does the prime minister agree with that
statement
i thank her very much uh i thank her
very much and i think that what the
country what the country is and what the
west needs sorry can i just say if you
don't want to go on the question i'm not
happy to pull stumps now but if we are
going to have questions i'm going to
hear the answers as well as the
questions prime minister
standing up you cannot sit down for a
bit
what the country needs now mr speaker is
a uk government uh working with our
friends and partners to stand up to
vladimir putin and to make sure that we
have a strong package of sanctions and
that's what we're doing
thank you mr speaker
the prime minister sets the culture at
number 10. why does he think that staff
members there
felt unable to raise their concerns
about the bad behaviors reported in
today
oh
mr speaker that is one of the
recommendations of the
uh the sugray inquiry that we are going
to take up to make sure that nobody uh
should feel that
in number 10 and that's why we're going
to review the code to ensure that nobody
feels that they have
any inhibition on coming forward with
any complaint that they may have uracil
mr speaker the prime minister and his
allies are trying to distract and
deflect from the truth but here are the
indisputable facts the prime minister
attended downing street parties he told
this house and the people that we
represent that he attended no parties
and in fact that there were no parties
the rules were clearly broken the
ministerial code has been violated so
when will he stop stop
insulting the intelligence of the
british people and do the right thing
and resign
mr speaker i i really think she's gonna
let the metropolitan police get on and
do their job
no no brenda no o'hara
mr speaker does the prime minister not
recognize that the public are rapidly
losing faith in the institutions that
they must be able to trust for
democracies to survive because it
appears that there is no individual no
organization no group or no force whose
reputation won't be sacrificed on the
altar of saving this prime minister so
can i ask the prime minister does he
consider the erosion of public trust in
the foundations of our democracy a price
worth paying to ensure his personal
survival yeah
speaker i believe that the foundations
of amongst the foundations of our
democracy our due process in the rule of
law and allowing the police to get on
with their job and that's what we're
going to do luke paul
thank you mr speaker part four
says that there is a culture of
excessive consumption of alcohol which
is not appropriate is there also a
culture of excessive drug taking in
downhill streets
uh mr speaker any drug taking would be
excessive and perhaps he should direct
that question to the labor front bench
mr speaker mr speaker
mr speaker
we've heard all about pre-judging things
today you only have to look at paragraph
three
of the general findings which talks
about things of leadership judgment in
different parts of number ten
at the cabinet office and it says some
events should never have been allowed to
take place another event should not have
been allowed to develop as it did other
than that's prejudging anything it's
pretty clear it's only one person in
charge of number seven in totality
that's the prime minister so let me just
remind the prime minister why this
matters about this real break in the
wake number 10 behave let me quote a
constituent one of a number of emails i
had constituents who lost loved ones
she said to me we received a call at 11
15 pm on the 29th of may 2020 saying mum
was deteriorating both my sister and i
drove to the home and spent the night
sat on a chair
outside her bedroom window watching her
die
all i could do was sub and shout to her
and tell her that i loved her i couldn't
even hold her hand that's why you should
go prime minister
prime minister
mr speaker i totally understand uh the
feelings of his uh his constituents and
uh i accept that uh things could have
been done better in uh in number ten as
i've told the house before but uh
really i must ask him to uh study what
uh sue gray has said and and and and we
are acting on all her recommendations
thank you mr speaker can the prime
minister explain how changing the civil
service hierarchy will prevent him from
breaching the covet regulations as he
has admitted
in this house
when will he take responsibility for his
own actions stop hiding behind other
people my constituents don't want
another government department they want
him to resign
prime minister
mr speaker
she's wrong on what she said and i
directed what i've said earlier
thank you very much mr speaker it's been
further revealed that in april 2021 as
the prime minister partied he also
swiftly rejected the idea of bereavement
bubbles for those who'd lost loved ones
suffered miscarriages
stillbirth or a child neonatal death
far from getting it he's deflected
laughed and smirked his way through this
statement he's a disingenuous man isn't
he
[Music]
yeah he is prime minister
uh mr speaker i know uh this has been uh
a harrowing and tragic experience for
the entire country uh we've done our
best to uh to deal with it and uh i as
for what she says about what's been
going on in number 10
i asked her to look at the report but
also to wait for the other police
inquiry
owen johnson
yeah
thank you mr speaker now this afternoon
we've heard the distraction the
deflection there's confusion and we
can't even get the answers to the most
simplest of questions about whether we
can actually get the full report
published when it's available so mr
speaker could ask the prime minister is
it the case now
that we're looking at a situation of
hubble hobble quite quack
minister
mr speaker
nothing would uh give me greater
pleasure than to publish everything that
we currently have but the fact is mr
speaker that there are legal impediments
and we have to wait until uh the police
inquiry is concluded so william cash
thank you mr speaker um i i accept
entirely what the prime minister has
just said it is absolutely essential
that we wait
it's absolutely essential that we wait
until we hear the next stage in this
these proceedings in relation to any
future investigations i'd also like to
draw attention to the historic
achievements of this prime minister in
the nation in the nation too
not only delivering brexit but in
relation to delivering the vaccine
rollout and in relation to his dealings
with mr putin and i believe that
everybody should take that most firmly
into account
i thank you very much and i think he's
completely right uh and uh he might have
added by the way that we have the
fastest economic growth in the g7 uh mr
speaker thanks to the steps this
government uh has been taking
courage
thank you mr speaker we've established
that there were parties we are just
really arguing about who is responsible
and as the honourable member for thorax
said earlier that's a minister so if
it's not him is it the member for surrey
heath or north east cambridgeshire who
should be facing the sack
prime minister
i
remind the honorable lady what sue gray
says in her
paragraph no such conclusion can be
drawn uh so far mr speaker she must wait
uh she must wait for uh the conclusion
of the inquiry
mr speaker the prime minister announced
at the weekend that he would be calling
president putin to urge de-escalation of
the situation in ukraine
the mirror have just reported
that today the call has been cancelled
because he's been dealing with the sue
grey report so can the prime minister
confirm that on a matter of such grave
importance that this report is correct
and that would be speaking to vladimir
putin as soon as he leaves the chamber
prime minister mr speaker i'll be
speaking to president putin as soon as i
can
thank you mr speaker
there i have read the report in full and
i think the most striking sentence
was the one
that there were failures of leadership
and judgement in different parts of
number 10 and the cabinet office at
different times
my constituents have been writing to me
whilst the prime minister has been
speaking
say that he should resign but they also
want to know the full facts
once the met has concluded
why could he not then publish the full
unredacted report prime minister
mr speaker we have to see
where the police get to have to see the
conclusion
of their inquiry we'll have to see what
the legal position is then mr speaker
mohammed jason
thank you very much mr speaker
why the speakers are deeply troubled and
angry by the frequent scandals engulfing
the prime minister's administration
because it's not just the party gate and
ongoing cover-up
but but all the other things
the program of parliament the treatment
of the queen the three point five
billion a chronicle with contracts
the writing of 4.3 billion carbon loan
fraud
and the russia report to name but a few
sussex university researchers have
warned that boris johnson's
administration is more corrupt than any
other administration since second world
war does the prime minister knows this
doesn't he
prime minister
well i i think the honorable gentleman's
point is completely ridiculous he
mentions uh he mentions what we did uh
for instance to get brexit done which
was absolutely crucial to restore public
trust in democracy
richard holden thank you very much mr
speaker like me many of my constituents
have been appalled by the reports of
what's been happening in number 10 and
will welcome the fact that my rightful
friend has come to the house today and
has apologized in a first step to
responding to this will he assure me
that he will continue to keep the house
updated on the implementation the
measures he's taking in the report and
also will he ensure that there's full
cooperation from the whole the number 10
team uh to the enquiries from the met so
they conclude as swiftly as possible
prime minister
yes mr speaker of course i will keep the
house updated and of course uh everybody
now in number 10 will cooperate uh to
the full uh with the mayor
speaker this is surely now
a new low a prime minister of our
country forced to come here to the
mother of parliament and plead the fifth
in a criminal investigation because he
knows if the truth is told it will
incriminate himself so let me just ask
the prime minister a simple question if
he cannot get his facts straight about
whether or not he was at a party in his
own flat how will anyone in this house
ever believe a word he says again and
how will our partners around the world
ever put their trust in him
all right let's just think i'm not going
to
dignify that question with an answer
except to say uh except to say that he's
got to wait everything he said is
completely prejudicial
hello
mr speaker i thought people are
lancashire were supposed to be straight
speaking because i i can assume showed
people that my constituents are calling
the prime minister a lot more than a
wally once i can't repeat reality is
here we'll get staff we're too
frightened to raise concerns about
behavior when you were ongoing half the
staff invited to bring your own ghost
party didn't turn up because he knew it
was wrong but yet the prime minister
said he thought it was a work event and
within the rules
his lack of leadership and judgment is
also shown by the elected bodies pile
high comment about a second lockdown the
one thing leader of scottish torres has
said that it's true is this prime
minister is not fit for office now given
he'll do anything to save his own skin
does that mean the leader of scottish
stories are going to get banned as well
prime minister
uh
mr speaker i directed i've said earlier
on
mick whitley
i think you know no one said in this
house here this afternoon
155 000 people died of covet that's why
we introduced the rules
but this is simply not the comprehensive
report that the british republic would
promise for so long but at least it's
clear in its findings that there were
serious failures and i quote so observe
not just the high standards expected of
those working at the house of
governments but also of the standards
expected of the entire vicious
population at the heist of the pandemic
does the prime minister accept
responsibility for his failure to live
up to the standards which the vegetables
would expect it's a poll
speaker
i take responsibility for everything
that happened in number 10 and the
government did throughout the pandemic
harry gardner
the great report
is clear that there should be no
excessive consumption of alcohol in a
workplace
can the prime minister
got excessive and in particular
that his judgment was at no time so
clouded that he was in danger of telling
the truth
uh but the answer is no if he thinks i
was i i've drunk too much now
which norris thank you mr deputy speaker
the prime minister wants my constituents
to suspend their disbelief and wait for
the met police to report
in which case will at least give them
clarity that should the metropolitan
police issue him with a fixed penalty
notice for participation at his party he
will resign
he really needs to wait and see what the
what the met uh decide
andrew
thank you
we've had
excessive what about
bluster
and bravado from the prime minister i
suggest to him politely that we need a
lot more humility from him given that
whilst the grey report might be
paper-thin
it's very clear in the serious failings
at number 10
fish rots from its head can i suggest to
the prime minister it's not a new prime
minister's office we need it's a new
prime minister
well i i i hear him and i simply repeat
what i've said earlier on uh i'm
grateful to sue grey for taking action
uh following her report but he needs to
wait for the conclusion of the inquiry
patricia gibson thank you mr deputy
speaker sue gray has made it clear
that this is not a report but it's an
update on the investigation into covered
breaches and downing street
indeed her in her update ms gray says
she is extremely limited in what she can
say and quote it is not possible at
present to provide a meaningful report
if it is the case that there's nothing
to see here move on as the prime
minister today is desperately trying to
convince us why has he repeatedly
refused to commit to publish the film
report even after the police
investigation has completed and what
does it say about the benches opposite
those populating them
if they still lift them genuinely think
that he is the best amongst them to be
prime minister
that's not what i've said
neil coyle
thank you mr deputy speaker the prime
minister told parliament and told the
british people that there were no
parties we now know he attended several
including one at which he was ambushed
with cake in his most pathetic excuse
yet given his previous statements which
we know to be patently false how does he
explain why this report says at least 12
parties in his home a warrant police
investigation
he's proved several times in that
question that he hasn't got the faintest
idea what he's talking about and he
should wait for the outcome of the
inquiry
the speaker the prime minister and his
apologies up to now had explained these
things away as one-offs you know a work
to
uh ambushed by a cape all those kind of
things but this report makes clear that
it was a repeated pattern of behavior
the booze ups after work that nobody
else was having all our constituents who
followed the rules
so can i ask him as well it also says
that there was
there's an investigation of a downing
street party on the 13th of november
2020. why did he tell my honourable
friend for haunting wood green on the
8th of december that no such gathering
took place and subsequently he's told my
right honourable friend our leader
that anyone who from that dispatch books
tells mr truth should resign
is he a man of his words
this is because she needs to to look at
what i said and she's look at the
outcome she needs to look at the outcome
of the inquiry
thank you very much mr deputy speaker um
the prime minister said in a statement
earlier that he understands the anger
of people in this country but does he
also understand
that while they've been watching this
for many people in this country their
greatest fears about how this would be
handled have been realized they've seen
an apology yes but obfuscation delay
tinkering rather than an acceptance of a
responsibility
the prime minister says he wants to go
on and deal with the important issues
facing this country perhaps the only way
we will be able to do that
is for the prime minister to accept that
he has become an obstacle to it and
resign
no mr speaker we're going to get on with
the job
jeff smith
thank you mr deputy speaker the prime
minister was wrong in something he said
earlier the sugray update can be both
damning and incomplete
and most of us can only guess how much
more damning the full report is going to
be and his colleagues should worry about
that i think he knows how bad it's going
to be because he knows what's going on
so isn't that the real reason why i
won't commit to publishing the report in
full when the police have completed
their investigation
prime minister no mr speaker he's
totally prejudging the whole thing he
needs to contain himself no he needs to
contain himself and wait for the police
to complete their inquiries
drew hendry
thank you mr deputy speaker the su-grey
update is not the report that this house
deserves it is not the transparency that
the public were expecting but it does
make it very clear that were there were
failures of leadership at number 10. the
prime minister is the leader at number
10. so will he now pack his suitcase or
will he leave it to his officials to
carry his cans
mr speaker he just needs to
look at the uh report again and he needs
to wait for the conclusions of the
inquiry
matt weston
thank you mr deputy speaker
look her in the eyes and tell her you
never bend the rules
a lot of us remember that campaign cost
tens of millions of taxpayers money
on the 13th of november in 2020 he bent
the rules didn't he
mr speaker i
refer him to what i've said earlier on
in this house
and uh frankly mr speaker he needs to
wait until the conclusion of the police
inquiry
even flynn
thank you mr deputy speaker this morning
the conservative party in scotland
issued a press release and it stated and
i quote the pandemic sees rise in
criminals getting away with kindness
were they talking about the prime
minister
mr speaker what we're actually doing is
cutting crime uh by 40 percent putting
uh 20 000 more police 20 000 more police
on the streets
thank you mr deputy speaker
week in week out throughout this
pandemic i like many of my colleagues
had to deal with constituents who
couldn't see their dying relatives or
grieve with them and some of us were
directly affected when we lost family
members and loved ones the prime
minister's actions have made a mockery
of the british people's sacrifices
during the pandemic and now he's the
subject of a criminal investigation it's
a new low for our country and our
democracy and it makes a mockery of our
democracy to the rest of the world if
the prime minister takes responsibility
for everything that he's
that has happened as he has said
isn't it time that he put his party
this parliament and the country out of
their misery and steps down so that we
can move on and focus on the national
interest because at the moment it is not
possible because of the crisis that he
had and number 10 have created
no mr deputy speaker
carol monahan yeah yeah yeah
thank you mr victor speaker it's clear
that the prime minister has used these
parties like many an under par manager
to buy popularity and favor yeah can the
prime minister tell us if he's using the
same techniques when negotiating
treaties and trade deals with
international leaders
prime minister
uh no mr deputy speaker
rachel maskel
thank you mr deputy speaker today should
have been about contrition and remorse
and it seems that the prime minister
doesn't understand the meaning of sorry
instead it has insulted the people that
have suffered and sacrificed for the
last two years
one question that many people want to
know is who is paying for these
investigations the police
and uh sue grace reports and who is
paying for his legal advice is it the
taxpayer
prime minister
i must say i think that
she's wrong in what she says uh as as
for who is covering the police costs uh
the police are covering uh the police
costs
jc
[Music]
cooper so
as far as the front cover he would see
it was called an update it is because it
is an update that it makes public trust
in the mets investigation even more
important the public must know that the
met will investigate without fear or
favor so can the prime minister confirm
that not at any single stage anybody in
number 10 or the cabinet office has
sought to influence the met's decision
on delaying its investigation or was the
delay a result of its own incompetence
no
mr deputy speaker and uh the only people
calling into question the uh the mets
independence uh i think the the side
opposite on our adventures
thank you
the promise has seriously misjudged the
mood of the country and indeed he has
misjudged the mood of his own
backbenchers my constituent wrote to me
devastated and upset
he couldn't see his disabled son
his elderly mother with dementia and his
newborn child putting a serious toll on
his mental health like millions across
the country he followed the rules but
the prime minister thinks he's above the
rules
instead
he blames his civil service and he
restructures will he do the decent thing
and resign
mr speaker i disagree with her
profoundly because i i i do understand
uh people's feelings and i do understand
why this is so important for people but
i i must say that i think the best thing
now is for the
inquiry to be concluded and in the
meantime for us all to get on with the
work that i think everybody wants us to
do
marion fellas
thank you mr deputy speaker and i have
enjoyed the exercise this afternoon
i've also like wanted to enjoy the prime
minister's answers to questions but
unfortunately he's duck dived he's done
everything but answer questions about a
party on the 13th of november about
whether he'll put out the final report
okay i'll ask him one more asked already
if you get a fine a fixed penalty fine
from the metropolitan police after all
this is over will you pay it yourself
and ask a tory donor to pay it for you
uh
this is because there's a process we've
got to wait for it to conclude
barbara keeley
thank you mr deputy speaker
among those who were the most isolated
during the pandemic were people with
learning disabilities cut off from
visits from their families not even
allowed an advocate if they were
admitted to hospital
for too many restrictions to services in
the awful isolation without visitors
that the pm's rules expected them to
follow were a matter of life and death
the mortality rate for people with
learning disabilities from kobe was
eight times that of the general
population
when he thinks about the damage done to
all those groups who are so isolated and
their families and the serious failings
of leadership and judgment in number 10
found by this independent investigation
how can he think his position is
terrible
prime
mr deputy speaker she's entirely right
about the suffering of people with
learning disabilities and indeed all
vulnerable groups who are exposed to uh
to lockdowns for for long periods and
that's why actually uh we worked so hard
to make sure that we could get this
country out of lockdown and keep it out
of lockdown and that was our objective
steer jose mr deputy speaker i don't
need to wait for the full sued ray
report
because this one tells me one important
fact
that we're a heck of a lot of parties
so can i ask thee
that we're a heck of a lot of parties
prime minister so let me ask the prime
minister at which point during this
catalogue of frivolity
while he was clearing last night's empty
wine bottles off his desk before
settling down to work the following
afternoon
did he conclude
that having one rule for him
and another one for the general public
was undermining his own health messaging
and costing people's lives
uh
mr speaker i remember mr deputy speaker
the honourable gentleman is uh
misrepresenting uh what sue gray says
he's also uh perhaps inadvertently uh
but he's also completely misrepresenting
what happened
tim johnson
thank you mr deputy speaker this report
confirms what we already know the abject
failure in leadership at number 10. so
will the prime minister take
responsibility and do what the
constituents and liverpool riverside are
asking for your resignation so that we
can get on and deal with the crisis
facing this country thank you
no mr deputy i refer to what i've said
earlier on
justin matters
thank you mr deputy speaker on the 8th
of december the prime minister told this
house and i quote i have been repeatedly
assured since his allegations emerged
there was no party and that no covered
rules were broken well just who gave him
those assurances because given he was at
some of the parties and at least one of
them was in his own flight he shouldn't
need anyone else to tell him what
happened so it looks like when the prime
minister spoke those words he was either
fooling himself or was he just trying to
fool everyone else
he needs to wait and see he needs to
wait and see uh what the inquiry
concludes and he and that is what due
process tomorrow and i stick mr speaker
by what i say
i can see eight people standing and that
is the last date i'm going to take just
to let you know
rachel hopkins thank you mr deputy
speaker section 5.1 of the ministerial
code says ministers must uphold the
bliss and partiality of the civil
service and not our civil servants act
in any way which would conflict with the
civil service code and finding six of
sugro's report which i have read says
some staff wanted to raise concerns
about behaviors they witnessed at work
but
that felt unable to do so
so does the prime minister agree with me
that if his staff and in fact civil
servants and workers everywhere feel
afraid to raise concerns regarding
inappropriate behavior at work that they
should contact their trade union rep or
join a trade union
deputy speaker that's why i've accepted
the conclusions of the uh sue gray
findings in full and
we will implement the changes
i assume that everybody's standing has
also been here for the opening statement
and throughout
caroline johnson thank you mr deputy
speaker mr deputy speaker i've listened
carefully to the statement the questions
the answers and indeed to my
constituents many of whom have been
devastated to hear that there may have
been parties and some of whom have
suffered great hardship i'm very glad
that the prime minister has come here to
apologize and to take on board the
recommendations but i am concerned that
this is taking time and attention away
from key issues this statement alone has
been going on for nearly two hours
the prime minister has achieved great
things with brexit and vaccines
but
there's two great things with respect in
vaccines
can he assure this house and me and my
constituents that this ongoing
investigation in the
organization of number 10 is not going
to take his laser-like focus away from
the issues that matter to them
yes i can give my honourable friend that
absolute assurance hillary ben
[Music]
thank you very much indeed mr deputy
speaker
has a date yet been set for the prime
minister to be interviewed by the
metropolitan police in connection with
their inquiry
the the police are independent and they
must get on with their inquiry
thank you mr deputy speaker this reads
like a dreadful poorly written soap
opera an unbelievable soap opera here
members opposites saying how important
it is for their constituents to go under
the detox my constituents are
incandescent at the behavior of this
prime minister will he accept the damage
he's doing to the office of elected
representatives all of us and will he do
the right thing and clear out yeah
[Music]
conditions that made them feel uneasy
perhaps even unsafe prime minister and
they also felt that they were unable to
say something people exposed their
potentially deadly virus unable to say
something in the workplace where parties
were raging on around about them at
least some says mrs gray represent a
serious failure to observe the high
standards expected of those working at
the heart of government who is
responsible for that prime minister
mr speaker he's completely represented
misrepresenting uh what took place
gavin newlands
come on
yes thank you much mr fps because
despite the
emissions from sugary's update it makes
crystal clear
that the office he occupies and the
government he leads behaved in a
despicable and disrespectful way when
the public faced the greatest of threats
does not accept this personal conduct
before becoming prime minister and since
is completely unacceptable and if he had
any respect for his own office the
public and did even a cintilla of
integrity it would announce his
resignation to the 1922 committee
tonight
no mr deputy speaker steve mcdonald
thank you mr speaker can i ask when will
the various statements made by the prime
minister from that dispatch box about
the subject of parties and gatherings
that demonstrate be investigated under
the ministerial code and isn't it
absolutely classical that's a question
for the prime minister at all yeah
mr speaker we have we have an
investigation going on i think it's very
i think that that's the one people
should focus on and they should allow
the police to get on with their job
richard thompson
thank you mr deputy speaker in his
statement the prime minister said sorry
for the things we did not get right
sorry for the way this has been handled
a generic non-apology that will mean
absolutely nothing to anyone that's
heard it but what i and millions of
others want to hear is apart from
getting caught out in all of this what
is it that the prime minister is
personally sorry for and genuinely
regretful for in terms of his own
conduct and if he just resorts back to
that entire hackneyed form of words that
he used to begin with doesn't it just
show that it's not a new office of the
prime minister that we need it's a new
prime minister in office
prime minister uh mr speaker i i've
repeated several times uh sorry i am for
any misjudgments that that i made uh and
i continue to apologize uh for them uh
and uh all i can say
mr deputy speaker is that we need to get
on and uh and await the outcome of the
inquiry but allow the government uh and
uh to deliver on the priorities of this
uh country and that is uh to unite and
level up uh to continue to cut crime uh
to make colossal investments across our
whole country and that is what we are
going to do
i'd like to thank the prime minister's
statement today and answering questions
for just short of two hours i'm just
going to pause as people leave
and others take their places for the
next statement
see so i'm a very good
we now come to the second of the three
statements today and we have the
secretary of state for foreign
commonwealth and development affairs
please trust
[Music]
mr deputy speaker with permission i
would like to make a statement on what
we are doing to tackle russia's
aggression against ukraine
moscow's malign intent is clear
they have massed over a hundred thousand
troops on ukraine's frontier
russian forces are continuing to arrive
in belarus
it is only eight years since russia
illegally annexed crimea and stoked
conflict in the donbass region so we
know the danger is real
they have been pursuing a campaign of
hybrid warfare aimed at destabilizing
the country just last week we exposed
the kremlin's plans to install a puppet
regime in kiev
this threatening behavior towards a
sovereign democratic independent country
is completely unacceptable
it is a clear violation of the
commitments and obligations that russia
freely signed up to from the osce
helsinki final act and the mink's
protocols to the budapest memorandum
which guaranteed to respect the
independence and sovereignty and the
existing borders of ukraine
the only way forward is for russia to
de-escalate pull back its troops and
engaging meaningful talks on the basis
of these existing obligations
that's why the uk is determined to lead
the way through deterrence and diplomacy
the prime minister will travel to the
region this week and later today the uk
will be joining discussions at the un
security council to apply further
pressure on russia to take the
diplomatic route i will be flying out to
moscow over the next fortnight
this builds on our campaign of
diplomatic engagement over recent weeks
and months
i have led calls through the g7 nato and
the osce to urge russia to desist in its
reckless and destabilizing activities in
ukraine as well as georgia the baltics
and the western balkans i've raided
these raise these issues directly with
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
both the united states and nato have set
out areas where we could explore
reciprocal measures to increase
transparency
reduce risk and take forward arms
control
the ball is firmly in russia's court
while we're determined to accelerate
these efforts we do save from a position
of strength we are combining dialogue
and deterrence and that's why the prime
minister is considering options for
further deployments of our armed forces
to reinsure and protect allies on nato's
eastern flank
we're preparing to offer to support nato
with additional fast jets warships and
military specialists
as nato's biggest spender in europe on
defense we are prepared to deploy our
forces accordingly
we've been very clear that a united
alliance would meet any further russian
invasion of ukraine with massive
consequences for russia's interests and
economy
and we're preparing an unprecedented
package of coordinated sanctions with
our partners which would impose severe
costs
today i am setting out our readiness to
act
we will be laying legislation before the
house that will significantly strengthen
our hand in dealing with russia's
aggressive action towards ukraine it
will go further than ever before
until now the uk has only been able to
sanction those linked to destabilization
of ukraine
this new legislation will give us the
power to sanction a much broader range
of individuals and businesses
we will be able to target any company
that is linked to the russian state
engages in business of economic
significance to the russian state or
operates in a sector of strategic
significance to the russian state
not only will we will be able to target
these entities we will also be able to
go after those who own or control them
this will be the toughest sanction
regime against russia we have ever had
and it is the most radical departure and
approach since leaving the european
union
those in and around the kremlin will
have nowhere to hide
we will make sure
that those who share responsibility
for the kremlin's aggressive and
destabilizing action
will share in bearing a heavy cost
their assets in the uk will be frozen
no uk business or individual would be
able to transact with them
and should they seek to enter the uk
they would be turned back
laying this legislation now
will enable us to act in concert with
the united states and other partners
rapidly
multiplying our collective impact
we will use these new powers in a
targeted manner designed to damage the
interests of those who bear the greatest
responsibility for russia's actions and
exert the greatest pressure to change
course
i will not say now
exactly who we may target or with what
measure
but moscow should be clear that we will
use these new powers to maximum effect
if they pursue their aggressive intent
towards ukraine nothing is off the table
we are also standing with our ukrainian
friends by providing vital support to
help them defend themselves
that's where we're supplying the country
with defensive anti-tank missiles and
deploying a training team of british
personnel
we've already trained over 2 21 000
members of the ukrainian army through
operation orbital and in addition we're
stepping up our investment in ukraine's
future
ramping up support for trade
up to 3.5 billion including 1.7 billion
to boost ukraine's naval capability
we will continue to stand united with
ukraine
mr deputy speaker
it might seem hard to believe that in
the 21st century the citizens of a proud
sovereign european democracy are living
under the threat of invasion
we know from the lessons of history that
this course of action would benefit no
one
i do not believe that ordinary russian
citizens want to enter into an
intractable quad bar of needless death
and destruction that could drive at the
rival the soviet afghan war or the
conflict in chechner
indeed we have no quarrel whatsoever
with the russian people only with the
policies pursued by its leader
it is time for the kremlin to step back
from the brink to de-escalate and enter
into meaningful dialogue if they do not
they should be in no doubt we will be
ready to use the powers i have set out
today to maximum effect
we will join our allies and partners to
ensure such reckless action will bring
huge consequences at massive cost
we will defend freedom democracy and the
rule of law i condem i could commend
this statement to the house
well mr deputy speaker
can i thank the right honourable lady
for advanced site of her statement and
for our discussions on this issue i'm
very grateful
mr deputy speaker as we in the
opposition have been clear since this
crisis began we stand in resolute
support of ukraine's sovereignty
and in opposition to russian aggression
we support the essential international
diplomatic efforts to achieve the
escalation and the defensive support
provided to ukraine
i said in kiev two weeks ago and i say
it again now
on these benches we believe it is
important to send a united message from
the whole of the house
that is why we welcome moves by the
government to lay the groundwork for a
robust and extensive package of
sanctions against russia in the event of
any incursion or attack on ukraine
we believe these message measures must
be broad severe and comprehensive
they must apply widely to crucial
sectors of the russian economy without
gaps or loopholes
they must target
corrupt elites who stole their money in
our country they must target not just
relevant russian entities but those who
enable
who support
who service who facilitate their
activities
so can the foreign secretary confirm
that uk subsidiaries of any new
sanctioned targets would be cut would
not be carved out of scope
we know that some oligarchs have used
their wealth to seek influence and
protect themselves from criticism
so can i ask for her assurance that
these measures will be applied without
fear or favor
given these measures were pre-briefed
and include broad categories of
potential targets can i ask her what
assessment
she has made of the risks of asset
flight and what steps she's taken to
protect against that
mr deputy speaker these sanctions are
conditional on russians actions
their purpose is to form a serious
deterrent which when matched by unified
action
and the work of the g7 nato and the osce
will make president putin think again
but there is much more
we must do irrespective of the decisions
made by president putin
things that it should not have taken an
army threatening ukraine to put in place
things the opposition have repeatedly
urged the government to address
for years the labour party and
colleagues from across this house have
raised the alarm about the role of dirty
money
in keeping putin in power
mr deputy speaker for too long our
defenses have been let down at home
while the government looks abroad
warning after warning report after
report the government has been asleep at
the wheel london is the destination of
choice for the world's kleptocrats
we are the home to the services and the
enablers who help corrupt elites to hide
their ill-gotten wealth
we have a system of corporate
transparency that permits the products
of larceny on a grand scale to be hidden
under our noses and the result is the
embarrassing spectacle of president
biden being warned that the widespread
presence of suspect russian money in the
uk could jeopardize britain's response
to this crisis this is not a matter
simply of individuals though welcome
though that is it's about fixing a
broken system our openness to fraud and
money laundering our inadequate
regulation of political donations our
lacks mechanisms of corporate
governments are weakness to foreign
interference so can i ask the right
honorable lady where is the economic
crime bill the government just pulled
where is the comprehensive reform of
companies house
where is the register of overseas
entities bill
where is the foreign agent registration
law
where are the new counter espionage laws
where are new rules on political
donations where is the reform of tier
one golden visas where is the
replacement of the outdated computer
misuse act where is the reform of the
electoral commission and why does the
government's election bill make these
problems worse
by enabling political donations from
donors based overseas
mr deputy speaker the right honourable
ladies
movement on sanctions is welcome
but there is much much more to do
these steps at home are not distinct
from sanctions or diplomacy abroad
they must perform part of a unified and
coherent response
one that has been urged consistently by
the chair of the intelligence select
committee if she truly wants to fix the
problem she must start there
[Applause]
[Music]
well first of all can i thank the
shadow foreign secretary for his
constructive approach i think it's vital
that all
members of the house
demonstrate their support for freedom
and democracy
in the face of severe aggression
by the russian regime not just on the
borders of ukraine but also through
belarus
into the western balkans and in fact
across the world and i will take forward
the united message that i've heard from
the whole house
on to
our friends in ukraine who very much
welcome
the support that they have been offered
by the united kingdom both the economic
support uh the support in terms of
defensive weaponry but also the support
in the face of russian aggression
this package that we are putting forward
in legislation will be in place by the
10th of february so we are
able to enact wide-ranging sanctions in
broad categories that really target
anybody that is providing strategic or
economic support to the russian regime
there will be nowhere to hide and we
will apply those sanctions without fear
or favor i am very clear about that
mr deputy speaker we've already taken
steps to tighten up our regime on
corruption and existing and illicit
finance through the criminal finances
act 2017
the global anti-corruption sanctions
regime we've put in place we're
reviewing all tier one visas uh granted
before the fifth of april
and we will be introducing the economic
crime bill the prime minister committed
to that at the summit of democracies
with president biden at the end of last
year let me assure the house that our
priority is the defense of freedom and
democracy
that comes before any short-term
economic interest for our country but
also the whole of europe we must wean
ourselves and others off dependence on
rotten gas we must target
uh the criminal and corrupt money and
that is what we are determined to do
with this extension of our sanctions
regime the most radical we have done yet
from chicken heart
thank you mr deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to hear from my writer and
friend the foreign secretary about the
tightening of this sanctioned regime
something that she knows that the
foreign affairs committee has called for
for four years
it's extremely welcome that she's
looking hard at dirty money and i hear i
find myself in agreement with my right
honourable friend the member for
tottenham
the need to clean up
the dirty money
in our economy is not just about doing
the right thing and standing up
alongside the people of ukraine it's
about standing up for the british people
defending ourselves against the
corruption that flows through our system
making sure that our houses our homes
are not being exploited
to pay murderers
on behalf of a dictator this is not a
foreign problem this is a problem for
the united kingdom to deal with at home
and the strongest thing we can do to
defend ukraine is to defend ourselves
against filth and corruption in our city
well my my uh my honorable friend is
right in the works that the foreign
affairs select committee has done to
champion uh this issue
this is why we are introducing a much
tougher
sanctions regime on russia and as i've
said we will be bringing forward the
economic crime bill to add to the work
we're already doing to tackle illicit
finance
thank you mr deputy speaker i'm grateful
also for site of the statement and uh we
would support it i've already said that
in this house that the snp will be part
of the coalition to defend ukraine and
indeed our democracy so it's not a blank
check because we will want to see some
details but you can
rest assured mr deputy speaker that the
snp will stand behind these measures i'd
be particularly grateful though for a
reassurance that scottish land scottish
limited partnerships will be included
within the package because they are a
clear
risk in terms of gbs transactions also
the property transactions need to be
part of it as well and a reassurance of
coordination with the eu precisely to
avoid asset flight given that these
measures have been telegraphed
but as well and i do want an answer to
this one i've pledged the snp support
for this i do want a statement from the
foreign secretary in response to pippa
carrera who's the political editor of
the daily mirrors
report today an impeccable journalist
with impeccable sources that there was
supposed to be a call between the prime
minister and president putin today
but and i quote here when the grey
report landed the russians were asked to
shift the time but they couldn't so it's
off
what in the name of hell impression does
that give to our friends and our allies
if it's true perhaps it's not i'd be
grateful for an assurance that it's not
true and if it is true i'd be grateful
for an assurance that that conversation
will take place
i can reassure the honourable gentleman
that absolutely nothing is off the table
in
terms of who and which organizations we
will target with these sanctions uh
we're very committed to working with our
partners including the eu and we had a
big discussion at the g7 in liverpool
about the sanctions regime i've had
discussions since then
with joseph burrell and my eu
counterparts to make sure we're fully
coordinated as well as with the us and
the prime minister uh will shortly be
speaking to
president putin and as i've said i will
be traveling to moscow in the next form
in the next fortnight to speak to my
counterpart sergey lavrov
dr julian lewis thank you mr deputy
speaker cutting out a cancer is both
painful and dangerous
is the foreign secretary aware that the
previous intelligence and security
committee in its russia report drew upon
the expertise of edward lucas who today
has a comment column in the times headed
britain has become addicted to dirty
money may i suggest that if she wants to
be sure that this cancer is indeed going
to be cut out of the body politic and
the wider country's economy she could do
far worse than to consult mr lucas
before she finalizes her proposed
sanctions and their structures
okay
well i thank my honorable friend for his
suggestion i'd be very happy to meet uh
the gentleman he mentions
stephen kenneth
thank you mr deputy speaker the
government said six months ago that it
was finalizing its report into how more
than 700 russian millionaires were
fast-tracked for british residency by
its so-called golden visa scheme
can the foreign secretary tell the house
when this long overdue report is going
to be published and does she agree with
me that the reason for the delay relates
directly to the four million pounds
that's been donated to the conservative
party by seven individuals who have deep
and highly dubious
links to the criminals
and secretary
we are reviewing the tier one visas that
were granted before the fifth of april
and uh i'm sure the home secretary will
have further to say about that in due
course
mr deputy speaker could i welcome both
the statement and the wider steps the uk
is taking to support uh ukraine my
concern is that western tactical
responses are actually playing
into putin's own strategy seeking
meetings with putin for example actually
plays to his self importance any
sanctions actioned will drive russia
ever closer to china
exactly what putin wants to do and
sending nato reinforcements around
ukraine but not in it is not the way to
deter an attack i worry that we are
missing the bigger picture putin is
using this ukraine crisis to
geopolitically realign russia militarily
economically and geopolitically with
china with massive security implications
for the west would my right old friend
agree the only way to halt an invasion
and check this dangerous trajectory is
to support ukraine militarily this is
our cuban missile crisis i encourage
britain to lead the call to deploy an
offensive alliance and stand up to
putin's aggression
secretary
our approach in dealing with this
issue
uh of russian aggression is both
deterrence and diplomacy that's why the
uk has been at the forefront in
supplying defensive weapons to ukraine
in training up
ukrainian forces and working with our
allies many of whom are also
supplying defensive support
into ukraine but we have to be clear
that there is a difference
between a member of nato
who does have a security guarantee such
as you know baltic states like estonia
where uk
uk troops are in place and the situation
in ukraine and in my view the best way
of deterring
uh vladimir putin from an invasion of
ukraine is first of all making it very
clear that this will not be simple or
easy this is likely to result in a
quagmire as we have seen in the savior
afghan war indeed in chechner and
secondly that there will be severe
economic consequences and those severe
economic concerns are of course
sanctions
that target
oligarchs and target companies
close to vladimir putin but also
the not going ahead of nordstrom 2 i
also think is very important for the
russian point of view but it is
important
mr deputy speaker that we do talk to
russia and we do communicate these
messages we will not resile
from our position about the protection
of the open door policy and to nato but
we will communicate direct with russia
so they understand those messages
thank you mr speaker the foreign
secretary comes to the house and talks
tough and says that there's a readiness
to act
it's four years now since the foreign
affairs committee produces russia gold
report which outlined corruption uh in
the uk it's two years since the internal
security committee
published hits report into russia which
outlined the similar uh concerns
why is the gov government acted in those
years and can i ask her if we are going
to implement sanctions how can we
believe that will be effective without a
strong political will and determination
to actually make them work
well we have taken a number of measures
in recent years namely the criminal
finances act 2017 the review we're
conducting of visas and what i'm saying
is that the most
far-reaching sanctions regime will be in
place by the 10th of february making
sure that russia understands that there
is a severe package ready to be in place
and of course i am absolutely prepared
to do what is necessary to make those
costs severe
john whittingdale
um my rightful friend is right that our
argument is with president putin and his
cronies not with the russian people
but she will be aware that russian
citizens and indeed many in eastern
ukraine are able only to access russian
propaganda from state-owned or
oligarch-owned media channels while
independent journalists are put into
prison and the internet is censored
will she look to see what more can be
done perhaps through the bbc world
service and the tech platforms to ensure
that the russian people are able to
access objective and factual reporting
and secretary
well my my right honourable friend makes
an excellent point and of course we're
looking at all of the channels we can
communicate through directly to the
russian people as well
as to the russian government and that is
something that i will be looking to do
on my visit to russia when i go there
chris bryant thank you mr deputy speaker
this is just week week weeks
honestly
since 2010 when the when the
conservatives came to power and they
first started saying they wanted to
press the reset button with putin we
have been weak ambivalent and
vacillating towards the russian
federation and we have no quarrel with
the russian people it is with president
putin
it doesn't work to try to look tough
when you've refused to deal with the
issue of tier 1 visas it's shocking that
the federal foreign secretary doesn't
even have a proper answer to that
question this afternoon this has been
going on for ages we've been giving them
out to thousands of russian oligarchs
and she still hasn't got an answer or i
hope maybe she will have an answer now
to the question about um unexplained
wealth orders if we can't do then
how is this new legislation going to
make any difference
this is far far too late it's not a
question of the horse has bolted they've
invited the horse in sat it down at the
table and given it plenty to eat
foreign that he goes to ukraine and asks
the ukrainian
ask the ukrainian government
which which of their allies do they
think is giving them the most support
the answer is the united kingdom has
supplied more defensive weapons to
ukraine than any other of our other
nato or the foreign secretary one moment
please the question's been asked let's
hear the answer foreign secretary
the answer mr deputy speaker is
ukrainian government are very grateful
for the support the united kingdom is
given
and we are the largest supplier
of all of the european nato allies of
defensive weapons to ukraine
we have helped trained up the ukrainian
forces we're providing economic support
and the sanctions package that i am
announcing today goes far further
than the eu sanctions regime that the
honorable gentleman presumably supports
but william fox thank you mr president i
very much welcome what my right
honourable friend has said today
and it's quite understandable and right
that our focus is currently on ukraine
but isn't this just part of a bigger
picture what we have is a russia that is
trying to build an arc of instability
around nato from the arctic
through the baltic to the balkans and
the caucasus and doesn't this require a
sustained
and consistent and strong policy of
deterrence utilizing diplomatic and
economic and military elements and
wouldn't a good start be that all those
who are members of nato carry their fair
share of the defense spending
my my right honourable friend is
absolutely right and that is why
the uk is supplying support right from
the high north
uh through to the baltics through to the
black sea
uh
back backing up nato and
being the largest
defense spender of all of the european
nato allies and that is being recognized
contrary uh to what those on the
opposition benches say that is being
recognized by our allies in the baltic
by our allies in eastern europe and by
our allies in ukraine
mark bridger
oh sorry sorry mark you have to wait one
moment i was caught up in the moment
thank you mr deputy speaker
we can't sanction what we can't see
and while i welcome this statement
what i'd like some clarity on
is whether or not this new legislation
overseas entities because the foreign
secretary will know
that many of these oligarchs
hide their money
particularly in uk property
the press release from the fcdo says
that it's going to leave them nowhere to
hide
or is this whole finally going to be
closed
what the legislation we are putting
forward is about
is about being able to target
entities and individuals that are
of strategic or economic interest of
russian states so it's broadening it out
much more widely than before where we
would only be able to apply sanctions to
those who are actively destroy
destabilizing ukraine so this is
we can target asset freezing uh we can
target the
ability to enter the uk of those
individuals and entities
the register of interest she's talking
about is part of the economic crime bill
that is something being brought forward
by the treasury uh and the prime
minister has committed that that will
happen this year
mr pritchard thank you madam death
speaker oh sorry mr uh deputy speaker
we're both we're both out i apologize
so can i uh welcome the foreign
secretary statement today and the
announcement of uh new powers
uh long overdue but i'm glad it's this
government's delivery and delivering uh
by the 10th of february can i say to her
that this will also be welcomed by the
radha uh in kiev and also by the
government of ukraine is it not the case
that ukraine is not uh nato's border
it is not the eu's border but it is
democracy's border and that is why
ukraine
matters and can i thank her for
who got offices working hard galvanizing
opinion both in washington and across eu
capitals to ensure that we have that
strong defense strong deterrence and
strong diplomacy
well first of all can i thank my animal
friend for his work as chair of the
all-party uh ukraine group ukraine is
vitally important it is a
freedom-loving democracy
in europe
and
if we don't work hard which we are to
defend ukraine from russian aggression
that will simply encourage aggressors
around the world that is this is not
just a regional security issue important
though this is it's a global security
issue
i'm grateful mr deputy speaker like my
honorable friend i support much of
what's in the
statement and the statement says that
she won't
she won't name who or what
may be targeted with
uh sanctions but can she clarify that
whatever the new legislation looks like
it will enable
the government to take action against
kremlin
mouthpieces and outlets in this country
for example rt uk
[Music]
as i've said
i am not going to talk about the
individuals or entities
that could be targeted
but it will be
anyone who is of strategic interest to
the russian state or economic interest
the russian state and you can imagine
that is quite a broad list of people and
entities alex
thank you mr deputy speaker my right
honourable friend will know very well
that kiev was the original capital of
roofs it was an area of fabulous wealth
and education until invaded by the khans
and the russians and the russians called
them the tartars now there's many um
reports have come out of tens of
thousands of tartars have disappeared
from crimea and this human rights
atrocities not being able to be properly
investigated so does my writer will
agree with me that we must try and find
out exactly what has been happening um
to the tartar population and equally for
those who do not feel it is important or
we should somehow let russia have the
russian empire as president putin
outlined in his essay last year that
that goes against every principle of
freedom and democracy of standing up to
fascist governments who want to
ethnically cleanse people over centuries
of
hatred
my
my honourable friend is completely right
and let's remember
that russia actually signed up to
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity in the 1994
budapest agreement they signed up to
this and what they are seeking to do
is renege on their commitments
to
stoke aggression
and to seek to undermine ukrainian
democracy in a variety of ways whether
it's false flag operations whether it's
cyber attacks or whether it's trying to
install puppet regimes in kiev
thank you mr deputy speaker a few
minutes ago the prime minister stood at
that dispatch box and said in response
to questions on partygate and i quote
this is the government which is bringing
countries together to stand up against
putin
but just last week our closest allies
said they went hope they went public
with their concerns over russian
influence in this country exactly so
will the secretary of state admit
that
her government has undermined
our diplomatic status and our national
security by refusing for so long to take
seriously russian influence and dirty
money
i don't accept the honourable ladies
talking down of the uk role
it was at the g7 meeting in liverpool
that we agreed with our allies including
the united states including the eu and
including japan
that the russian regime would face
severe consequences on an incursion with
ukraine and that language has now been
adopted by all of our allies and
partners we've led the way in providing
defensive weaponry to ukraine we've led
the way
as we are today with our package of
economic sanctions which goes beyond uh
what we were able to do as a member of
the eu
thank you mr speaker the time for
deterrence diplomacy is now over the
last two weeks from kramer tours to the
nets from kiev to sarajevo civilians has
been clear with me that they believe the
west will either save them
or there will be bloodshed in europe
what consideration is my right or behind
given to blacklisting russian banks and
will she look at joining the us in
sanctioning milara dodec in bosnia whose
ethnic
nationalist separatist genocide denying
agitation also risks bringing bloodshed
to europe yeah
well my
i know my uh honorable friend has
recently been on a visit
uh to the western balkans and we are
absolutely looking at what more we can
do on sanctions
to the regime there
as well as how we target some of the
russian entities she talked about jeremy
corbyn thank you deputy speaker
any war on the borders between ukraine
and russia will be utterly disastrous
for the people of ukraine the people of
russia and the future of
peace across the whole of the continent
of europe
so when she travels to moscow
to have discussions with the russian
government i hope she'll be able to
reassert the agreements reached the
1990s in recognizing ukrainian
independence but will she also
try and take the whole thing a stage
further
and a new disarmament agreement with
russia revisiting the previous
agreements and will she ensure that the
british government the british
state is represented at the
vienna convention on nuclear weapons in
the middle of march as a way of taking
forward de-escalation of stress and
threats as a way of
winding down the tensions on the border
because if we carry on building up
massive troops on both sides of the
border something awful is going to
happen and it'll be very hard to get out
of it
let's be clear here it's the russian
regime that have amassed the tanks and
troops on the ukrainian border it is the
russian regime
that have
escalated
aggression
not just towards ukraine but also
through belarus and in the western
balkans and it's the russian regime
that needs to step back before
they end up entering into what could be
and i do agree with the honourable
gentleman on that point a very serious
quagmire with appalling consequences for
the people of both ukraine
and russia and that is the point i will
be making uh when i travel to moscow in
the next fortnight
of seeley
mr speaker i thank the secretary of
state for her very robust approach
and this is not a criticism of her but
we still lack a comprehensive and
coherent approach to dealing with
russia's hybrid war this is frankly a
decade too late and no criticism of her
and clearly deterrence isn't working
my question is on uk facilitators which
has been mentioned by a few other people
does she understand how corrosive it is
to have young uk service personnel
ordinary kids in uniform in forward
position in the baltics whilst a morally
vacant and corrupted class in london of
lawyers bankers reputation launderers
and compromise style private
investigators coined it serving the
needs of a parasitic murderous oligarch
class who are part of a neo-fascist
regime now threatening war in europe
what are we doing about this corrupt
facilitator class
[Music]
well as i outlined earlier we have taken
action against illicit finance and
corruption
we've established the national cyber
security center
we're working very hard to support
ukraine uh on the cyber attacks they're
facing from the russian regime and what
i've announced today
is a sanctions regime but which is by
far the toughest
sanctions regime that we have
we've ever had against russia
hillary ben
thank you very much indeed mr deputy
speaker
um
the foreign secretary's announcement
today shows that the government can act
very speedily when it wants to the
these measures will be on the statute
book by the 10th of february
can she therefore explain to the house
why we are still waiting
for all of the other measures that my
right honourable friend the shadow
foreign secretary referred to
in his response to the statement why
can't those be acted on as speedily as
the sanctions she's
well as i said we have put through the
criminal finances act 2017 our global
anti-corruption sanctions regime
we're reviewing the tier one visas and
we will introduce the economic crime
bill which is
something that her majesty's treasury is
working on
daniel
thank you mr deputy speaker the foreign
secretary is absolutely correct in
highlighting that our partners in
central in eastern europe poland and the
baltic states recognize the leadership
that britain is
providing with regards to these new
tensions but they also recognize the
increasing divergence between london and
berlin
in terms of how to tackle russia over
these nefarious behavior
will she agree with me
that it's
important now to go back to our german
partners and re-emphasize the need for
them to stop the nordstrom 2 pipeline
it gives the russians an umbilical cord
to the heart of europe we
import less than 1.4 5 of our gas
requirements from from russia the
germans import over 60 percent of their
energy requirements for moscow
i had a discussion with my colleague
foreign minister babel uh last week
about precisely this issue and i do
welcome the statements from her and
chancellor schultz on nordstrom 2 being
very clear
that
it won't go ahead in the event of a
russian incursion
we do need to reduce dependence on
russian gas i welcome the work the
united states is doing to look at how
supplies can be augmented uh we're
working with partners across the middle
east this is a strategic issue for
europe and we do need to reduce
dependence on russian gas there's no
doubt about it ella mcmurran
thank you mr deputy speaker over 4
million pounds has been donated to tory
mps including
to a quarter of the current cabinet by
russian linked individuals
dirty money
is this what and this is from
an evil regime is this why the
government has so far failed to take the
russian threat to our democracy so
seriously
yeah
and how will what's announced today help
and also
will she pledge to this house to fly at
least business class to moscow in the
next couple of weeks
instead of using half a million pounds
of taxpayers money
as she did when she
[Music]
we have government planes for a reason
it's for government ministers to use on
government business
thank you mr speaker in addition to
targeted sanctions against
kremlin-linked individuals our friends
and allies in the u.s senate are
considering three further steps one
would be to sanction
russian state banks to prevent the flow
of foreign capital
secondly would be to have export
controls on key technologies that are
useful to the kremlin and thirdly a
number of senators led by ted cruz in
the u.s senate are proposing a return to
sanctions against nordstream itself and
related entities and individuals linked
to the organization will each of those
be included in the bill that she intends
to bring forwards
well as i've said the legislation we're
bringing forward is very wide-ranging
and targets
a number of sectors and interests in
relation to the kremlin and i can assure
my honorable friend that nothing is off
the table
then bradshaw thank you mr deputy
speaker our american allies have just
issued an unprecedented rebuke to the
british government um saying that any
new sanctions would be worthless as long
as london remains the main international
laundry mart for the laundry mat for
dirty russian money and i remember this
prime minister tried to
stop the publication of the russia
report and remove the whip from the
right on normal gentleman who now chairs
the intelligence
security committee when his own patsy
candidate failed to get the job i'm
still not clear though whether she is
reinstating the economic crime bill
because that's not been said on the
record from the dispatch books before if
she is can the admirable lord agnew have
his job back please
so
as i have said already this afternoon we
remain committed to bringing in the
economic crime bill and the prime
minister committed uh that that would be
done this year
richard drax thank you mr deputy speaker
the right older friend from north
somerset rather took my thunder
but it's such an important point i'd
like to raise it if i'm reiterated if
ever there was a reason to take a fresh
look at nato and its role and
responsibilities this threat by russia
of invasion in europe must be it
can my right to a friend uh tell us
are the other nato countries that are
not spending two percent has she spoken
to them has she given the reassurance
that they will spend two percent and if
they haven't what does she intend to do
to make them spend two percent of their
gdp
we are already spending more than two
percent of our gdp we're the largest
european
nato supplier of uh troops and security
around
around europe and we want to see
others step up because as the honourable
gentleman says these threats are getting
worse
uh we've seen an increase in aggression
and we need to see all nato allies step
up and fulfill their commitments
lucas
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
the government's attempt to claim some
kind of moral high ground on the issue
of russian sanctions is sheer hypocrisy
when her party has accepted donations
from oligarchs her government has turned
a blind eye to kremlin meddling in our
democracy and has held open the door to
putin's cronies to have their money
laundered in london so can she tell us
whether that is the reason that there is
still this delay when it comes to the
promised register of overseas entities
to shine a light on russian ownership of
british property in her replies both to
the honorable member for exeter and
indeed for oxford west and abingdon she
showed a remarkable lack of urgency to
know that this economic crimes bill
might come sometime this year is not
good enough when we're talking about
what pressure can be brought to bear on
russia now
well
i hoped the honourable lady would
welcome the fact that we are introducing
our toughest ever sanctioned regime on
russia which will be pla in place by the
10th of february we are acting with
urgency
to deal with this crisis
rick smith thank you uh mr deputy
speaker i warmly welcome the actions my
right or friend
is taking uh there should indeed be
nobody who thinks they are safe from
sanctions so can the foreign secretary
confirm that this new legislation will
ensure that any company of interest to
the kremlin would be able to be targeted
so there could be nowhere to hide for
putin's oligarchs
we will be able to target any company
that is linked to the russian state in
gauges of business and economic
significance to the russian state or in
a sector of strategic significance and
we won't just be able to target those
entities we'll be able to go after those
who own or control them so the net is
very wide ruth cadbury
thank you mr deputy speaker i'm going to
give the foreign secretary a third
chance
does she agree that the uk
will continue the uk government will
continue to look weak on the russian
threat while tory mps and members of the
other house continue to accept cash from
russian links individuals
well i had hoped the honourable lady
would be welcoming the package of tough
sanctions we're introducing
one other item of